Variance,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Keith Weber,
ladies and gentlemen.
Finally we meet.
I've worked out to your voice many times.
Your sleek athletic body on the beach,
swinging kettlebells,
making people work out along.
And uh,
we got you on the podcast,
man.
I've been talking about your videos for,
I don't know how long,
I don't even know where I found it.
I found it somewhere online and I was looking for some video to work out too and
it's just,
it was so bad ass,
you know that I'd just been,
we started selling it on a.com became like our best selling DVD.
You were constantly out of stock because we were selling them out for you,
but a,
it's fucking awesome video man.
So it's good to have you on.
Thanks for having me Joe.
It's amazing to be here with the book.
You got notes and shit.
Well I thought I should just in case I forget something.
What,
what was,
what would you want to bring up that you like had to write down?
Ah,
well,
you know what,
like I thought I'd be really nervous and I thought maybe there'd be some
important stuff I forgot about.
There's some parts of the video that are really hilarious that I didn't want to
forget to mention because I've looked on the Internet about some of the comments
people put and most of them are actually positive than ones I've read and
there's a few that are quite hilarious,
especially then the most hilarious ones are obviously the negative ones.
So,
um,
yeah,
if you can get the closer you can get to this thing,
the better because it's very directional.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There you go.
Um,
the,
yeah,
you're always going to get negative comments,
man.
No matter what,
especially if it's a workout DVD,
this workout,
I'm not a meathead.
It was shown when you can give me fit.
I don't like the way he works out.
He tells me what to do.
I get sand in my eyes when I did his work out on the beach.
The beach is a good place to work out though,
because you get that feeling like of humbleness.
Like you're,
you're connected to that ocean behind you and you know,
you also the roar of the ocean and the feeling of the sand.
And it's a great like surface,
like it's a super good surface to run on.
You know,
if I think more people live by the beach,
we'd have a nicer,
sweeter world.
I agree.
Uh,
the thing that blows me away whenever we,
we always go on holidays at least two or three times a year to a tropical place
because my wife and I and the kids love the beach.
Powerful white people.
Proper white privilege.
That's for three times a year vacation.
There's a story behind that.
But um,
and when I see people running down the beach with the running shoes,
I just want to tackle them and fix their feet because their feet.
Yeah.
Cause feet are fixable.
Um,
what's wrong with most people in running shoes?
Running shoes?
Just bad for you.
I,
I wouldn't run a marathon without running shoes.
Like that would be crazy because of the pounding.
Well,
yeah.
You know.
Have you ever read the book she running or born to run?
No,
I've never read anything on running because there was a great comic named Bill
Hicks who used to make fun of Jim Fixx,
the guy who,
uh,
the running books.
Right.
Cause he was like,
what are you writing about?
Left,
right,
left,
right.
I could get done faster,
faster.
I,
yeah,
it's amazing cause we're in Venice beach right now and a lot of people run in
Venice beach and I totally get why runners get a bad rap sometimes because a lot
of people are running,
it really shouldn't be running.
Like in what way?
They're not strong enough.
It's just not in shape enough to be running.
Yeah.
Again,
you really need to have a lot of strength to run properly and really
like in Wa.
And how solid.
If you would take someone and they were thinking about starting out a workout
routine,
you would not recommend just running,
never,
never really interesting.
What would you recommend?
Uh,
I,
I wouldn't even recommend kettlebells right off the get go.
Unless you know what you're doing and you have a good trainer.
I would recommend someone that's just fresh off the couch and they don't want to
hurt themselves.
Find somebody that can teach you how to do some compound lifting.
Uh,
learn how to do squats.
Again,
learn how to do dead lifts properly.
Maybe learn how to do a pull up,
maybe learn how to do a push up properly.
Um,
all those basic old school exercises are so powerful.
Do you want,
do you deal often with people that are starting from scratch?
Because that seems to me to be a very daunting proposition for some folks who
have been kind of couch potatoes their whole life.
And then all of a sudden they're like,
you know what,
goddammit,
I'm going to get fit.
I really want to do something.
Like I have a buddy who's really big and uh,
he's been telling me lately,
he does a lot of shooting competitions.
Like he does like,
uh,
like,
those tactical things.
We run through a maze and you have to shoot at targets,
but he's too big and it's like God damn and I got to lose some weight.
But I could tell it's hard to just start doing that.
It's hard to just change your lifestyle.
We have patterns that we fall into.
You know,
you got your average everyday pattern.
He'd get up in the morning,
you eat some unhealthy shit,
you go to an office,
you sit in a cubicle,
whatever you do.
It's really hard to say today after work at six 30 I'm going to go and do
jumping jacks and push ups and Chin ups and I'm gonna get my shit together.
And that,
honestly,
that is the main impetus for the,
the video in the first place.
And I come across people that I treat all the time.
Keith,
I want to get into shape and you know,
how do I do it?
And that's what I do love about the kettlebells.
Like in a perfect world,
I would have them learn how to do the compound lifts slowly.
But the kettlebells provide the same idea,
same movement patterns without having to put a bunch of weight onto your body.
It's amazing that inertia and the momentum created by these things.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's uh,
so I do get a lot of people in my kettlebell classes that are starting fresh,
like amazing.
Like,
um,
the women that come,
usually it's women.
I don't know why it's a guys
don't like to go out of that comfort zone.
Maybe you think that's what it is.
Well,
maybe just a handsome guy with long blonde hair and chicks are looking to hookup
weapons.
A pitch can get them to teach me how to work out and work my way into his life.
No,
I don't think that's what I don't think.
I honestly think women have a different mentality.
I have a buddy I run hills with just a couple blocks from our house is a perfect
heel.
If you bust your ass,
it'll take you about two hours,
two minutes,
20 seconds to get to the top.
Like that's absolutely giving it everything you have.
So it's kind of the perfect length of a hill.
Kind of taps into that mid range energy system.
And there's mornings every morning,
the summer there's a group of women at this playground nearby.
It's 6:00 AM like 20 of them doing bootcamps and,
and pushups and burpees and things like that.
You'd never see 20 guys doing that.
At least I haven't.
You would if they were in the military.
Good point.
We probably,
uh,
like just on their own will and desire to be in good shape.
Most guys,
unless they're professional athletes,
if they're just the average guy that wants to look good and you know,
be like that guy in the fitness magazine,
they uh,
they don't like being in public almost.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Like women don't mind working on at a park,
like getting all together and yeah,
they doing that.
It's more than my finger.
They're a bit more social than us,
a little more social.
So,
um,
goes back to the hunter gatherer thing or something.
It probably sat around and talked with the hunters are all being really quiet,
sneaking up on shit.
I've heard that,
but I don't,
I don't know if it's true,
but yeah,
they talk a little bit about that in the book.
Born to run is an honor,
honor.
I recommend that book to everybody because it's a,
it will make you want to try running and running on the beach should be done
barefoot.
I believe so,
yeah.
That's the way you were all supposed to run anyway.
Right.
We're not supposed to run the way most people think because of those running
shoes that you're supposed to go heal first.
Right.
Because they've sort of changed people's gates with these shoes,
with his big fat pad near the heel,
which is really unnatural.
Correct.
Like the way the foot is designed,
you're supposed to land on the ball of the foot and the foot is actually
supposed to act as a bit of a shock absorber,
just slowly decelerate your weight.
And that is how a natural gait is supposed to be performed when you're running.
Right?
Yeah.
Um,
and there's actually,
there have been studies done where they've taken people and they blindfolded him
and looked at their gait patterns and then they put these big runners on and
they have a very similar gait pattern.
It's almost like you take away that sensory ability of the,
all those thousands of nerve endings in the ballroom of the foot to actually
feel what's going on.
So your body subconsciously puts the brakes on,
it makes you heel strike
the heel strike thing really didn't happen until,
what it was like the 1970s or something like that when they came up with those
running shoes.
He's an amazing that they,
they virtually change
the entire country or really all over the world.
The gate of people when they run by putting a big fat pad on the heel,
like we never had that before.
No.
And it's a,
it does,
it creates a terribly unnatural gate.
Um,
and it leads to a lot of injuries.
But
there are a lot of people that even if they started running in a perfect
scenario with the right shoes and everything,
if they're not strong enough,
uh,
there,
it's going to lead it
to some problems.
There really is important and it's one of the things that I always stress when I
talk to people about the onnit.com products that we sell the kettle bells or the
like the steel clubs,
things along those lines.
I'm like,
please just start slowly.
Men Don't want to pick up an 18 pound kettlebell.
Blackboard Fulcan Birch,
I could work over more,
but you're very,
your video with a 35 pound kettle bell kicks my ass.
Just 35 pounds.
You think that's not that big?
It's like a four year old,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
if you can carry it for women,
carry four year olds in their arm,
you know,
my wife's carries our four year old all the time.
She's about 35 pounds.
I mean,
that's all that is.
And you're,
you're doing this workout and it's the beginning.
It seems like,
wow,
this is not that hard.
But then a minute in you're like,
Holy Shit,
how long is this going to be?
And then you realize that just one kettle bell,
just one simple 35 pound kettlebell.
If you follow your workout,
you can get an absolutely brutal routine in.
Yeah,
it's a,
and it's kind of,
um,
for me it's a measuring stick.
I like to use my video at least once a month to test myself,
make sure I'm not getting lazy or kind of starting to fall off the rails because
I'm just like everyone else.
If I don't stay with it,
I can get,
you know,
a little bit lazy.
Yeah.
Everybody can if they don't have some sort of a goal.
Right?
Yup.
That's one of the cool things about your video is just you have to keep up with
it.
Like I bought a bunch of videos before they were excellent.
Like Maxwell has a bunch of videos and a Mike Mauler has a bunch of videos.
Mike Mauer is very much into technique and yet in showing the fundamentals of
the movements and things along those lines.
But what I really liked about yours is just a,
you have to already know that shit and it's just hardcore ready go,
let's do this.
And that.
That was the big thing when I first started doing kettle bells.
I think in o two,
I think I took their for their second instructors course with dragon door.
Um,
yeah,
there weren't any videos out there that just for people that knew what they were
doing.
And so I had,
I bought every video in the book and I shouldn't say that there were a couple
that were,
uh,
for people that knew what they were doing,
but they were,
I just don't think they wanted to hurt anybody.
Right.
And I had seen,
I'd been teaching kettle bells by the time I made that first video for at least
three years.
And I'd seen what these ha,
again,
mostly women housewives that were coming fresh off,
not exercising and what they were putting themselves through and they weren't
getting hurt.
They were just getting really good shape.
And so I thought,
I'm going to put a video together like we do in class.
And I did have a lot of requests from people saying,
make a video.
I can't make it to your class.
I'd love to have something to just pop into the DVD player at home.
It'd be awesome if there was something like a class or something,
like a really common class that was taught were people that had never worked out
before.
It could all get together so they didn't feel like freaks.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
So you don't like show up at the gym and these all these fucking Bros all
stuffed it up and screaming and throwing weights around and dropping them after
they lift and it's very intimidating.
There's a place you could go for folks who are just cubicle jockeys.
You know what have you.
People that are like,
you know what?
I just need something different.
This is it.
I'm going to,
I'm going to take this class and my workout for the first time,
like a war,
a first timer workout program.
That would be awesome.
And I think honestly kettlebells give you that.
That's the closest thing you could ever get to something for everybody because
it's,
it's a lightweight and it's uh,
it's such an equal stress on the body.
Like,
you know,
like you go to the gym,
they'll,
you'll do bench press and arms and the next day he can't move your,
your pecs and arms are just fried.
Where's the Kettlebell?
Your whole body is fried,
but not to the extent you can't move as long as you're sensible about it.
So and moving it all together.
Oh,
there's one,
one move,
one unit rather.
Yeah.
I always find it that it translates the best to actual athletics too.
Then when you do things like deadlifts or squats or any big compound movement,
it just,
it translates like you actually feel physically stronger when you do something
like martial arts or grappling things along those lines.
I think that has a lot to do with the acceleration to like that's the goal.
It's like exercise.
I love to throw an exercise I love to hate.
It's a,
because you have to develop a lot of acceleration to get that Kettlebell over
your head,
especially when you're getting tired.
That's why I like to put the thrusters after you've kind of done a couple of
exercises to fry the legs and shoulders.
I think the man maker,
I think it's a,
I think it starts out with,
it actually starts out with a thruster.
Um,
but a lot of the other chapters there's,
I sent it,
slide it in there when you're really fatigued and it forces you to get that
acceleration and then that translates over to the strength.
So did you ever work one on one with a,
any MMA athletes?
Um,
I did,
like we were talking about,
I did work a little bit with Jason.
Jason McDonald.
Yeah.
We're talking about before the show.
And uh,
and we did,
we went for,
I'm not sure how many workloads,
at least half a dozen because he's,
he trains,
he was training,
uh,
like twice a day.
So these were just sort of to supplement his training and uh,
but I think it was a little much with everything else he was doing.
So,
but I think he won his next fight,
so maybe it helped.
That is a big issue with MMA fighters.
It's like doing just the right amount,
like you don't want to do too much so that you're burnt out when it comes to
your skill training later on the night.
Like when it comes to like technique,
martial arts technique.
But a lot of guys do like to do their strength and conditioning first to wear
themselves out so that when they
do their sparring,
they try to be more technical because they've already exhausted and they can't
use strength.
There's like two schools of thought when it comes to that.
Right now there's one school of thought that says you should roll really tired.
And then there's another school of thought says you should do all of the
strength and conditioning after you've done all your technique works.
So your technique could be like a sharp as a razor and then after you could
worry about getting sloppy when you're running up hills.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's really a,
it carries over almost to the strength training world as well.
Specifically,
I'm like,
I know,
uh,
Paul [inaudible],
he's very much into strength with kettlebells.
He's one of the guys that brought kettlebells to America,
right?
Yeah,
I think he was teamed up with John Mccain and they sort of collaborated and,
uh,
I think the story goes,
um,
John said he would publish a book for Pavle if he would sort of bring
kettlebells to American,
let him manufacture them.
And it must've been like late nineties.
And before that,
no kettle bells in America.
I think there were,
but a few,
I don't think it was mainstream.
I mean,
I don't think,
I think it was one of those things that probably sat at the back of a gym and
hadn't been touched in 20 years because no one knew what to do.
Okay.
Right.
And then amazing as something could be around in Russia for so long and didn't
make it to America.
The nineties.
That's so weird.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
well,
yeah.
The,
and when they first came out with Kettlebells,
they had 16,
24 and 32 kilograms sizes.
That's it.
And I came across kettlebells.
Um,
actually Pavle would put articles in the odd,
I don't know if you remember the magazine Muscle Media 2000,
but no,
it was a,
a Bill Phillips published that one and he was the guy that first came out with a
the 30 or the 12 week body transformation challenge and you could win a car.
And it was through eas supplements and it,
anyway,
I was in terrible shape.
Uh,
my son was just born,
so I want to hang out at home with him and didn't go to the gym for like eight
months at all.
Maybe once a week I'd go and I'd felt more and more pathetic every time I'd go.
It was horrible.
Um,
my son has a theory about that,
but uh,
so I was in really rough shape and I remember people that knew me were saying,
hey man,
you should do this body transformation challenge.
And in my mind,
I was still in awesome shape.
I mean,
oh yeah,
good idea.
You know,
I think,
why was everyone telling me this?
But the key to that program was you're supposed to take a before picture.
And I remember my wife took it before a picture of me in the middle of winter,
you know,
didn't have UV light for four months at least.
And uh,
I looked horrible.
I actually,
uh,
you saved it.
I saved it.
Yeah.
I actually carried around on my phone just to let you know how far you've come.
Well,
and just even to remind me to stay disciplined.
Right.
Cause like I said,
I'm a just like everyone else,
like I,
I can fall off
the wagon pretty easily.
But uh,
so you took this before picture.
Yeah.
And then you did the challenge.
Yup.
And then I fell,
I fell in love with the whole Bill Phillips Muscle media concept and read every
magazine cover to cover.
And I sent my pictures into muscle media and,
uh,
I didn't win anything.
I might have one,
a sports bag or something like that,
but,
but the,
the after pictures were quite astounding,
comparatively.
And I will admit,
uh,
you know,
I had a bit of a Tan and I maybe got a haircut and you yourself up a little bit,
but not to the point where a lot of people I knew that were doing the challenge
did cause I think that's just a,
so not genuine like to like there was one guy,
he was dehydrating himself for three days.
So we look more ripped and you know what I mean?
And there's another guy that uh,
uh,
you know,
was taking like loads of creatine so he could get pumped up a little bit more.
And like that's one of the things that everybody used to love about fade,
fade or million ankle.
The former uh,
pride champion and one of the greatest mixed martial artists ever is that he was
always kind of dumpy.
He had like a little gut,
like a little spare time and you always like thick,
big,
thick Russian dude,
but you know,
never worried about what he looked like.
He was just fit.
And he was always in great shape too,
which is really kind of astounding.
Like the gun never gassed out.
I mean,
he was always an excellent shape and you know,
never had a six pack and it's fucking life.
Not one time where he's fighting at least.
Yeah.
Well that's one thing with the sport I'm sort of doing now,
at least in the summer,
our summers are really short,
so I think that's why I like try IFD triathlon now you're,
you're,
you live in Alberta?
In Alberta,
yeah.
It's that summer like is like a week long.
Very short summer.
Yeah.
It's a,
and what we do get is oftentimes not so great.
It's so beautiful up there though,
man.
Yes.
Oh God.
I was up there in June.
It's amazing.
It's so gorgeous.
So much trees and animal life and everything up there.
Yeah,
it's very natural.
It's a,
yeah.
So anyway,
you were saying,
uh,
your winter times,
summers are very short.
Some are short and never judge a book by its cover.
That's where I was going with that.
Like you'll have people doing these triathlons that you're there in front of you
for most of the race and they're huge and they're there.
They don't have the typical athlete body type at all and they're just like thick
guys.
It should be playing rugby or something like that.
And they're,
they're still fast.
So they must have a powerful engine under their tongue to cart that carcass
around that's 50 pounds heavier than me or then also probably heavier than it
should be.
Oh yeah.
Right.
I mean,
there's a lot of people out there that are in really good shape,
but they're fat.
You know,
like,
I know this dude,
I want to say his name,
but he's a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
He's had a big fat belly,
but the fucking guy doesn't get tired.
Man.
Your role with them,
he knows how to conserve energy and he's under that belly.
He's strong as shit,
like his core and his legs and everything's very physically strong,
but he's just got a lot of fucking pizza and his body.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's a,
I was thinking about that the other day.
Why?
Because people ask me a lot about what I eat and I don't think I eat
particularly crazy,
uh,
in terms of disciplined until I hang out with someone that I always wonder
about.
Like,
uh,
and I won't say any names here,
but there's a couple of buddies I have that there,
you know,
they do triathlons,
they're working out all the time,
they're doing stuff,
but they got a little bit extra.
And so all I need to do is go for a bike ride with them.
We're going to go for a two or three hour long bike ride to find out why.
And during these bike rides,
these guys will consume like I'm not even hungry and we're in a one hour of the
ride.
I'm just starting to warm up.
And these guys are,
they've already chowed down an energy bar.
They're drinking this sugary Cytomax or whatever type solution without
electrolytes in it.
And it's just like one,
it's like a feast.
This is really our bike seeing some sort of like Christmas dinner and it's,
and they do that every time they train and it's almost,
I don't know what,
what caused it,
if it's like a human survival instinct that I'm exercising.
So uh,
I,
you know,
I got to keep pounding food in or what but I think it's just cause they have the
food right there.
You know,
there was some study recently about uh,
rehydrating and they were talking about like how much more people rehydrate if
they're around things that tastes good.
Like if you have like sugary drinks,
like a Gatorade type drink,
like how much more you'll drink than if it's just water,
right?
Yeah,
we're just gross gross slovenly
and sugars,
like those simple sugars,
like those are really not good for you.
Mean you didn't get away with eating them after you work out because your body
is sort of glucose craving.
But the,
the reality of those kinds of sports drinks and stuff like that,
it's like this does,
I'm fucking healthy for you at all.
Those are corn syrup when look saloons.
Now,
that doesn't mean 30 mother fuckers.
Well I think most of those sports drinks or are owned by companies that produce
soft drinks.
Yeah,
I'm sure a lot of them are for sure.
A lot of them are for sure,
but they say the chocolate milk is the best thing to drink right after your
workout.
Is that true?
It's,
I guess it depends who you talk to and I think this is based on some studies
that they've done,
but if you talked to anyone that's a in the Chinese medicine or like my wife's
really into Ayurvedic Medicine,
milk is the demon.
It's like they,
what do they say?
They say it's drinking plus and no cause drinking,
pus.
How's it drinking?
Pus.
They hate milk.
Who are these people?
Well anyway,
have they ever eaten cookies because milk without cookies,
it's just bullshit.
Cookies without milk router.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a lot of people into this method of eating and eating for your body type
and everything.
And anyone that's a,
there's three things in Chinese medicine that caused a lot of phlegm.
And in Chinese medicine,
phlegm is not only what you hack up when you're exercising,
but uh,
energy blockages in the system.
So the top of the list is dairy.
Uh,
second is peanuts in third or bananas.
You can't eat peanuts and you can't eat bananas.
No.
What kind of communist bullshit is this?
What are they trying to say?
Huh?
Bananas.
I know what the Fuck is wrong with bananas,
man.
I don't know if I buy this Chinese medicine and I did the people that brought
you rhino horns for hard ons.
Isn't that the same focus?
Uh,
yeah,
they do all sorts of crazy stuff.
How about tiger bone make you strong?
No,
it won't just kills fucking tiger.
Tom Ass.
Yeah.
So I take all this stuff with a grain of salt.
You should take it all with a couple of grains of salt.
Salt's good for you.
Tiger bone.
Not so much.
Are you into like that kind of acupuncture,
acupressure,
all that stuff.
Yeah,
we do that at our clinic.
What,
what kind of evidence is there that that stuff works?
Is there ever been like peer reviewed studies and acupuncture,
especially in Asia?
Yeah,
there are a lot of studies in Asia.
Uh,
when I took the course initially,
there was a lot of,
again,
studies from Asia that indicate like memorize studies where they're taking an
Mri of a person's brain and poking needles in different points.
And there's,
they're showing like major brain activity in different parts of the brains.
Never understood it,
but I've always liked looked at it curiously because I'm like,
wow,
so many people for so many years have been sticking needles in themselves.
There's probably something to it,
but you know,
like I've heard people criticize yoga and one of the things that they say about
yoga is that it's just stretching.
Like my friend Penn Jillette from Penn and teller,
they did this,
uh,
episode of Penn Jillette's bullshit,
Penn and teller's bullshit.
You remember that show?
Yeah.
And they did one on yoga where they were like,
it's just stretching.
It's just true.
And they were showing,
and I want to say,
listen man,
this ain't cool.
You guys are out of shape.
You don't really,
you're not really working out.
You're not.
If you do yoga,
it doesn't seem like it's anything more than stretching,
but if you do yoga,
you get high.
That was just a fact.
If you do like a big rooms class,
you do like a 90 minute yoga class,
you will feel high at the end of it.
It's just a fact that is unavoidable.
I mean you can't deny that it's undeniable and to say that that's just
stretching that all you're doing is just moving your body around.
Man,
I don't think so.
Those skinny little motherfuckers from India,
I've been doing that shit for a thousand years for a reason.
There's something to it.
They've figured out something.
They figured out some way to tap into your endorphin system in some major way so
that you get a big reward when you do like a long yoga class.
It's a very piece sort of inducing movement or a series of movements.
Well,
and it goes,
a lot of these uh,
uh,
systems coincide with each other.
So with Chinese medicine,
uh,
they do cheat gone.
And so that's all about bringing the breath in with,
with the breath comes out like a breath of fire.
Is that the same thing?
That's a variation of it.
Um,
Chigong
is more for a healing yourself through energy cultivation.
So you're bringing the energy in through your lungs and then you're doing
certain movements or tie cheese and other good example and you're stretching
those,
those energy meridians that go through your body while you're breathing in.
So the,
in the in breath brings the CI in and then you do these particular movements
that that forces that ci down.
Your Meridians cheesy though.
Is there,
if there,
is anybody ever like shown ci and Mri?
Like what's going on when he's saying,
look,
you're forcing your cheat,
is it circulation?
Is it just your,
your focus,
your energy?
Like what is it?
It is that,
and it's also,
I believe that they've shown that there are electromagnetic forces going across
our skin.
Apparently they found acupuncture points in cadavers and it's an acupuncture.
I'm going to help all the needles in you want like an acupuncture point is
actually an area of lower energy resistance,
lower electrical resistance.
And it's,
it's uh,
on it.
We all have them and they're all in the same place.
So when they're using needles and they're sticking them in various parts of your
body,
like how do they know where to stick them on?
What does it based on?
Uh,
mostly it's based on,
believe it or not,
your body dimensions.
So your body dimensions would be different than mine.
So I would figure that out by using my hand.
So the width of my hand from these knuckles here would be three cin,
three Chinese inches.
Now your hand is,
might be bigger than mine.
So I would use this part of the knuckles for the three cheese partier.
Yeah.
If euro say had a smaller hand,
I would use these knuckles here.
I want you to know when to decide.
Like,
what if you've got a medium hand,
you don't want to be off with your needle placed.
Well,
acupuncture points are about the size of a dime.
Okay.
So it was a bit of wiggle room there.
But I think,
uh,
I think a lot of these people that do it all the time and the people that are
real hardcore Chinese medical practitioners,
they,
I think they almost have a sense of where the energy is to ever see that movie
with Steven Seagal was in a coma for a long time and they put some acupuncture
needles in and he came out of the car,
start fucking people up.
He had the,
he gave himself the acupuncture needles with the Moxa yeah.
With the glowing incense at the end of it.
So one is called Yep.
So when we,
uh,
took her Chinese medicine,
we took a few courses,
but the,
the best one we took was a,
at the nearby university.
Right where you did your show last in Edmonton.
And the guy there,
doctor Ong is a master.
He comes from many generations of Chinese medical doctors and he's from Burma
originally,
but he's also a western medical doctor.
So he kind of has a nice perspective on things.
He's not just one sided,
he's and uh,
but he loved walks up.
He,
oh,
he liked that stuff where it,
and it smells.
It's sage.
If he didn't,
why they call it mock to then watch called sage.
That's with all the names.
I just tell people call it sage mark.
So
someone copywriting Moxa is,
it marks a TM.
So you take this,
um,
siege and you put at the end of the needle.
What purpose does it serve at the end of the day at all?
I've always wondered that she more cheat.
So it not applying it,
taking it rains.
That's where I'm out.
That shit don't work.
You can't,
he can't get more cheap by a burning thing that's in the end of a needle.
How does it give you more cheap?
It warms up the needle.
Oh,
okay.
Well actually actually makes sense.
Okay.
I take it back and come back in
and there's two types of mocks.
So there's the type that you stick on the end of the needle and then there's
like a big long stick,
like a big cigar and you liked the end of that and then you wave it over
different [inaudible] like there's a major energy point on our belly button and
that's actually a forbidden point in Chinese.
Same with your nipples.
Hey,
you don't want to be putting needles in these places,
penises and other one of them.
I'm pretty sure the scrotum also like so they're smart.
They knew where not to put the needs.
Don't put needles in your penis.
How fucking smart out of these people,
because they're not putting bases on the moon.
They're just saying don't stick needles in your deck.
I could have told you that.
I'm not even educated.
So that this,
when you say like major energy centers,
like an energy center in the stomach area.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
So that's where a lot of energy is stored.
Railing.
Yeah.
Is there a battery down there?
Uh,
no,
but it's,
it's almost like
a pool of,
of this vital energy that we breathe in.
Yeah.
But how's it stored there?
Um,
I'm just,
I'm challenging this because I'm playing devil's advocate first of all,
but also because I wanted to ask you about these things because I've had these
conversations with people and I'm always like,
I gotta go.
Like I can't,
people started going,
Oh,
I'm puling my energy and I'm bringing the Moxa enlightens my ci and like I gotta
go,
I can't,
I don't have the time.
So,
but you're here right now.
So I really want to know what the fuck is up with all this pooling of the
energy,
storing of the energy willing.
It's all shot.
That's a good,
that brings me back to the scientific part of it.
So these chakras are the same as major energy centers in Chinese medicine,
which are the same as our endocrine system.
So I suppose the Chakra and your navel,
uh,
would coincide with the adrenal glands.
Hmm.
How much of this stuff do you think is like,
things along the lines of,
uh,
acupuncture or you know,
this types of meditation,
how much of them are actually changing your state because you're just focusing
on it?
And how much of is not,
not necessarily a placebo effect,
but in the act of saying,
okay,
they're putting needles in various spots in my body.
I'm putting myself in a very calm place.
They're lighting the Moxa like just getting yourself calm and accepting the fact
that you're in treatment at that moment,
which is very different than you
would be normally.
Say if you have like a backache or something like that.
Have you have a backache?
Like,
God,
my back socks really been fucking with me.
But do you ever like sit down and try to calm your whole body and meditate it if
you did,
would that bring the same result of sticking yourself with a bunch of needles
and thinking about it?
I know what I'm saying.
Yeah.
It makes sense.
It totally does.
Um,
yeah,
because you are,
you're in this state and the mind is so powerful or is it both?
Is it
being in that state,
like calming yourself down and there's also an effect by the needles?
Yeah,
I think it is both.
I think there is having had acupuncture done to myself many times.
Um,
my take on it from doing it for a long time is these needles are going into our,
our skin,
which is a huge sensory map and the,
the needles are so fine.
They actually don't cut us there.
It's like taking a baseball bat and putting into a vat of Cook Spaghetti.
It,
it's so they're so skinny,
the other slide and it's really weird.
Yeah.
And didn't even hurt.
Like people think that they hurt you barely feel them.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I think it occupies a little bit of space and that,
that signals the brain that,
wow,
there's something going on here that I don't like.
So then it sounds sends down national antiinflammatories and sends down more
blood circulation,
almost a sets the,
the healing environment.
Have you ever done whole body cryotherapy?
No.
This is the shit you got to try this.
This is the,
the latest and greatest thing.
Like I had heard about Kobe Bryant using it,
but my friend Eddie Bravo,
when he's preparing for his match against Hoya Gracie and Metamorris,
uh,
he started using it on a daily basis and uh,
Allen Joe Band,
one of our fighters from a 10th planet,
we just fought in the UFC.
He,
he was,
his knee was hurt and he did it twice a day every day before his last UFC fight
and it totally fixed all the inflammation is knee.
You go into this tank,
it's like this box,
you know,
it's just like,
oh it looks like a meat locker,
right?
There's two different doors.
One door is where you take your clothes off and you,
you keep your underwear on,
you have earmuffs on,
you have a,
you wear a mask over your face and you wear socks and slippers cause the floor
is fucking ridiculously cold.
You have gloves on as well and you go into this room,
it's 250 degrees below zero and you'd go there for three minutes.
That's what I do.
I do three minutes because I'm not a pussy pussies.
They get out at about two minutes.
I fucking hang.
I don't even know if he should do three minutes.
Probably not even a benefit of going that extra 30 seconds.
But I'm a meathead,
so I continue.
Uh,
so you go in there,
you do three minutes,
and then you get out and I warm up,
I get on an elliptical machine and I do it for like the elliptical machine for
like 10 minutes,
get my body temperature up,
then I go back in again for another three minutes.
And it is,
it's ridiculously good for inflammation,
ridiculously good for any aches or pains that you might have,
like muscle soreness because your body freaks the fuck out.
It feels it's 250 degrees below zero and it just goes holy shit.
And it pulls all the blood from the surface of your down to your core.
Then three minutes later when you're out,
you know,
it's,
it's enough time so you're not dying of hypothermia.
You go out and then your body goes,
oh,
we're okay and we should all just rushes out.
And it's been explained to me and very technical and scientific terms,
all the different mechanisms that are going on in the body that are protecting
you from,
you know,
from this impending death by,
by cold.
And so when you're,
your body realizes that it's not happening.
Like what's,
what is the,
the,
um,
the actual mechanism that causes this anti inflammatory response.
But it's way better than these ice pass and people have been taking for a long
time and they sit in these things for 20 minutes.
This is way better and it only takes three minutes.
It's amazing.
You got to try it.
Have you tried the ice baths?
I've done an ice bath before.
You know,
it's good.
This is better.
It's not as painful either.
It painful.
Plus you don't have to get your Dick wet there.
I said that out loud.
I think,
um,
the,
the ice bath is a great thing.
I mean if you,
if that's all you have,
I mean,
they are painful and it's also good for your,
you like your spirit,
like your ability to endure.
Like,
I think that like being uncomfortable,
your ability to endure comfort or discomfort is a muscle just like everything
else.
And my friend Bob Calf Varella when I was,
uh,
back in my taekwondo getting days,
there was this guy who was one of the senior students when I was first starting
out.
He was a black belt when I was a white belt and his name is Bob.
And he used to live at the school and teach and train their bobcat.
Barela and Bob used to take fucking cold showers in the middle of January in
Boston.
He would just crank up the cold water and just get in that shower and wash like
nothing was going on.
And I would go,
I can't believe he's doing this.
I can't.
It's so called,
the water was so fucking cold.
And he'd be in there just,
just doing breathing exercises and taking a shower and everybody else to get the
fuck out of here,
turn that water on hot and take their shower.
But this dude,
he,
um,
he really believed in testing your spirit and he thought that that taking these
ridiculously cold showers,
like actually it probably in the long run,
it was actually good for your body.
Now that we're knowing about cryotherapy and things along those lines and ice
pass,
it's probably actually good like post workout for anti inflammatory response.
But it was also,
he believed that it would,
it's like a muscle that you're testing your will,
you know,
and by doing that and putting yourself constantly in that state of mind where
you can endure discomfort that you build up your ability to endure discomfort.
Yeah.
It's kind of,
again,
kind of like kettlebells.
Yeah.
I want to send you down there today though,
after this is over,
I want to send you down to that cryotherapy place.
Yeah.
You need to do it.
You need to do,
I want to hear what your response to it is.
Everybody that I've brought down there and they fight.
It's called Cryo healthcare in La.
And uh,
they're one of,
I think there's only two places in the whole country that have the very specific
type of cryotherapy device they have.
We step all the way in.
Usually there's one where your body's in,
but your head is above it and it's sort of like a liquid nitrogen that keeps you
freezing cold,
but that's not as consistent as the one where you step in,
you step in.
I mean,
your fucking heads in it,
your face is in it,
you're going to love it.
I can't wait.
It's just so cool that they're always coming up with these new ways to increase
the body's ability to recover new ways to increase your body's ability to fight
inflammation,
you know?
Well,
in a lot of it is based on,
they're just making something old better.
Like we'd known that,
you know,
probably cold showers are cold baths are jumping into cold lake is good or ice
on injuries.
Yeah,
yeah.
They've just taken it one step further.
It's amazing with the technology.
Yeah,
it really is.
It's,
it's super cool and you feel so fucking good when you get out of it.
When you go into it,
you're,
you are,
you're so god damn coal for those three minutes and when you get out it's like,
Ooh,
you get this wild at Trent Allen Rush.
You start like jogging in place.
You feel so good.
Your brain's firing pop out like we're going to live.
Yeah.
Your body is really convinced that you're fucked.
Like it's like you're naked and you were dropped off on the top of the earth.
I don't even think like the North Poles,
250 degrees below zero now.
Like what's the coldest spot on earth?
I would say it's probably like,
oh,
I'm going to guess.
Let's just guess.
I think where that sue Akins chick lives life below zero.
She's my hero.
That bitch lives in the middle of Alaska by herself shooting bears.
But uh,
I think that's like,
it gets to like one 91 90 below with the cold spot on earth.
Jeremy,
the highest ridge and Antarctica.
I'm trying to find the highest ridge and Antarctica.
The coldest thinness atmosphere somewhat is one 36.
That's it.
Yep.
Bitch ass one 36 seven and nothing cooler than dry ice.
Cold and dry eyes.
So this is,
oh,
nothing.
Just 114 degrees colder than that.
Wrap your head around that Sun.
That's fucking ridiculous.
To 5,250 degrees below zero and no frostbite.
Nope.
I'm a nipple a little bit,
but it's all kind of new.
New didn't need it?
No,
no.
You will.
You um,
you wear gloves,
you wear a face mask.
Uh,
you wear ear muffs.
Is that the spot?
Yeah.
Hundred 36 below zero.
Wow.
New Record for the calls.
Place on earth.
What happened to global warning?
Bitch?
I bought real estate up there.
I'm hoping for global warming.
I'm trying to set up a mall,
but the,
um,
the,
if that's the coldest place on earth still,
I mean,
it's amazing that this box is 114 degrees colder than that.
Wow.
114 degrees colder.
One 14.
It's called fuck.
And how many times do you do this?
I tried to do it a couple times a week.
Yeah,
it's,
it's really good.
And you go in and out a couple of times.
You have,
I don't,
I do it twice.
I go in to a for a little while.
Remember that dude from um,
the fresh prince will Smith's buddy was there yesterday?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he was doing it yesterday.
He was on dancing with the stars.
Yeah.
It's a great video.
He's a nice guy.
Very nice guy.
Yes sir.
I met him for the first time,
but um,
that,
that uh,
the response of your body like freaking out because of the cold and then warming
up and then doing it again.
It's supposed to be really doing it twice.
I supposed to be fantastic.
It sounds exciting.
I can't wait.
Do you do anything specifically?
Um,
like post workout?
Do you have like a routine that you do per post workout to reduce inflammation
or anything?
Well,
one of the things I do if I run,
and uh,
I read this in a book and I thought it was ingenious as a,
just lay on my back and put my legs up against a wall.
Oh.
Just to like let the blood flow down,
blood drain.
That makes sense.
Because you know,
a lot of times after your run you just sit down and hold off your something.
Yeah.
Cool.
And it just pulls and then I stand all day at work and uh,
it's hard for that blood to get back to the heart,
especially when there's all that inflammation in the legs and all that heat
created and all the blood just bashing down into there.
Uh,
so yeah,
it's uh,
it,
it makes a huge difference for your legs.
Do you work out with a trainer or do you concoct your own workouts and just are
self motivated?
Yeah,
I,
I dream up different.
Like my body is my own experiment and uh,
sorry
I didn't come out right,
but uh,
but it is that,
you know,
it's my body and I can see what it's capable of handling and uh,
it's fun to do.
There's so much information out there and so many cool things to try.
Uh,
but I do come back to the kettlebell training is kind of,
to me that feels like the hardest weight training type conditioning exercises
than I've found.
It's,
and it's just so convenient.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I just love the fact that you can get so much out of one piece of equipment.
You know,
with one 50 pound kettle bell you can have an unbelievable ball busting workout
and your whole body be ridiculously sore and all functional strength.
Like I love Turkish getups things along those lines because they're not
glamorous exercises.
But if you do them consistently,
like you feel like a difference.
If you go to help a friend move a couch,
like you feel it,
you feel like you can physically carry things better.
Like I said,
I was hunting in Alaska this week and I had a big pack on my back and I'm
climbing up hills and I felt great.
I'm in good shape.
I mean,
I'm going up these ridiculously tough hills and sliding around the dirt and
everything and it's a lot of like lifting yourself up with one leg and then
lifting yourself up with the and the other leg.
So it really is consistent with like the workouts that you create in,
in your,
in your videos.
Yeah.
You know,
that's,
that's a good point.
And it's,
uh,
I do,
I love the Turkish get up.
So many people don't like that exercise,
but this is not glamorous.
Yeah.
And it's,
it is hard.
You have to,
you can't watch TV while you're doing it right.
But I go skiing,
we go skiing in the winter and the most fun thing to do is climb up these huge
trails that people make.
They take their skis off and climb up to,
not out of bounds,
but this one hill we go to is like,
there's,
it's like the stair climber from hell,
Hey,
the oxygen's a bit thinner and you've got to get your,
you've got this stupid ski boot on so you can't flex your ankle.
So you're just going one after the other,
straight up these hills.
And exactly.
It's just like getting up.
You're,
you're used to it.
It's like getting up from the Turkish getup,
except you don't have to hold the weight above your head.
I just think that it's one of the best exercises for like translating into like
using your body in everyday life.
If you have to pick things up or move things or just be strong,
like have your body like,
oh,
you know,
it doesn't bother me if I have to move these boxes right now.
I could pick the cause like,
um,
like Ben from a hunting,
hunting.
Yeah.
We're talking to him.
Uh,
our friend from a band,
honey honey yesterday was talking about how they're on the road all the time and
he hurt his back from just carrying,
he's like carrying their,
get their gear,
just picking things up and carrying their gear.
Like just things along like everybody thinks of,
there's a lot of like vanity and ego associated with exercise.
Like if you look at the cover of all these magazines and dudes are all sleek and
six pack,
you're like,
fuck that Douche.
I don't even want to be that guy.
I hate when they,
they black them out or when they airbrush them.
That's the worst bothered the Bosnian.
Yeah.
It's just so fake.
Fake.
It's fake fuckers.
Well there's a lot of people that actually do look that way.
Right.
But that's the thing like for what you were talking about your friend that that
cuts weight and they dehydrate themselves before they take those photographs.
That's something that most people are probably not aware of.
When you look at those magazines and you see someone that's unbelievably
shredded and vascular and really thin skinned,
they're dehydrated and they're super unhealthy and they're like,
you can't stay like that either.
Like that state that they reach like contest wait state like right before they
compete in bodybuilding competitions.
They're like on death's door.
Those fuckers are like literally ready to die but it looks awesome.
Why does it look good to be almost dying?
I just think we,
we like that look of just solid muscle and just shred it.
Fucking tried to act.
Yeah.
Little Fat's good though,
right?
I think it is.
Yeah.
Good for your endurance it seems.
Yup.
Cause guys who were like super lean and shredded,
they don't seem to have as much endurance as guys who just have a clutch,
just a small layer of body fat on them.
Does your body actually burned fat?
Like if you're in a competition,
like say if you're doing something like a marathon,
is your body burning fat?
Are you basing,
is it going entirely on glycogen and food?
And like what is,
have you ever read the book eat,
stop,
eat.
All right that much.
Oh yeah,
you're too busy to read.
I read but I read shit on like space things that will never affect me.
I'll summarize it for you
cause it's,
um,
the best book I've ever read on eating.
Eat,
eat,
stop,
eat it,
eat,
stop,
eat.com.
Uh,
and I just found it,
I don't know how I found it,
but uh,
it's just,
uh,
it's like a ebook,
maybe a hundred pages and it's based on 261 research papers.
Uh,
anyway,
this guy,
Brad Pilon,
uh,
he worked in the supplement industry and he started wondering what the,
and his p Long P,
I,
l,
O n and he,
I think he started questioning the wisdom of six meals a day.
Do we really need six meals a day?
Does the body really,
uh,
you know,
a CAC,
its own muscle tissue if you're not constantly like full and uh,
and like his fasting really that bad.
So He's,
he looked at all these different studies on
the effects of fasting and it turns out you can not eat any calories for 16
hours before your,
your blood sugar levels even start to be affected.
You've got that much glycogen,
16 hours,
10 hours.
So you think it's like mental for a lot of people.
Uh,
I think it's mantle.
I think once your stomach is empty,
uh,
it's such a weird feeling for so many people that they almost freak out.
And,
uh,
so the premise of the book is too fast for up to 24 hours once or twice a week.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
just don't eat anything.
You can drink tea,
you can drink coffee,
nothing with calories and it and get,
get down to that last eight hours of the,
uh,
the fast that lasts between 16 and 24.
That's the sweet spot.
That's where the magic happens.
What magic?
Well that's where your insulin levels are like down to the bottom and your body
says,
oh my God,
look,
there's no,
there's no blood sugar left in our muscles and liver.
We better start burning fat.
Wow.
What a new concept because a lot of people haven't gotten to that,
that hunger stage where their bodies have actually been forced to access fat
stores.
So for so for is it the average person has that many hours of,
of showing.
I think that's based on average.
I know,
cause I wondered that too.
I'm like,
it seems kind of like a cut and dried number,
but as soon as that good for you to do that.
Very good.
Really?
Yeah.
And he's a lot of controversy when it comes to that though,
isn't it?
There is,
but he proves it like the book.
Honestly,
I couldn't put it down because everything,
every sentence he writes is backed up with a study and it turns out and he's got
charts and graphs and everything,
but when you get your insulin down to that level,
your growth hormone levels are inversely proportional to hear insulin levels.
So you actually get a surge of growth hormone.
So the how weird your,
your body makes more growth hormone if your body is starving because it's
stress.
I think it's under stress.
Huh?
And supposedly that's why we get a little spike of growth hormone in the middle
of the night because presumably if we've eaten,
suffered a certain hour,
by the time the middle of the night rolls around,
we've dipped our blood sugar down a little bit compared to what we were after.
We ate like four hours after.
And the growth hormone has a bit of a pump.
Is that where you're supposed to eat?
Like a fat
pig right before you go to sleep?
Yeah.
Yeah,
because then you're sleeping,
burning off while you're sleeping.
So how often do you fast?
I try for once a week,
once a week.
And how many hours do you do?
Just 24 you just do a full day once a week.
And he says that anything more than 24 is not that beneficial.
You've kind of maxed out the benefits around the 24 hour mark.
So when you come back after the 24 hour fast,
you slowly consumed food or do you have very specific foods that you consume
that you almost are forced to slowly consumed?
You're so sensitive to food and it's not even that long of a time,
but you like a piece of lettuce tastes good.
And uh,
you know,
like you drink a,
maybe a smoothie or something,
it's like,
oh my God,
I'm full.
It's incredible.
So your stomach is just like super sensitive to it.
Hmm.
You know,
animals like bears,
when they go into hibernation and they come out,
they really can't eat much.
They have to slowly work their way up.
It's kind of a crazy thing.
But grizzly bears,
when they come out of hibernation,
they kill things on instinct and just leave them there.
Because a lot of grizzlies,
when they come out of hibernation in the spring,
there's still snow on the ground and Moose gets stuck in the snow to the point
where they can't run away from the grizzlies because they're huge animals.
And the snow is oftentimes five,
six foot thick.
And I don't have to tell you,
you live in Alberta and as they're walking like they're fucking sinking all the
way to the bottom.
This smells like a moose can't sprint in seven foot deep snow.
They're really kind of fucked.
They're sitting ducks.
And so these bears come out of these holes and they see these moves just kind of
trudging and they just run up to him and fuck him up.
And uh,
my friend Cameron was up in Alaska and he said he saw his one bear had killed
like several moose and couldn't eat them yet cause he couldn't,
like he'd just come out of hibernation.
So he didn't need,
literally didn't have the ability to eat meat yet,
but he was just killing anyway.
Killed a bunch of Moose and just leave them all fucked up and the smell,
even my nice.
Really?
Yeah,
like literally.
Yeah.
It's amazing how nature works.
It's strange how nature works as far as like,
you know,
reacting to what you're putting into your body as far as like you're burning off
sugars because you're consuming a lot of sugars and then you stop that and you
give yourself only like complex carbohydrates,
vegetables,
proteins in your body goes,
whoa,
whoa.
Where's the sugar?
Where's your sugar?
Alright,
okay.
Change the script.
We're going to burn fat.
And that's,
you know what,
the Paleo has kind of a bad rap because it's sort of been proven that people
that lived in the Paleolithic era didn't necessarily eat that and they probably
did eat some grains and they probably did eat anything in the fucking they can
get their hands on.
But the reality being that simple sugars,
whether it's a lot of pasta,
a lot of bread,
cake,
those things are not necessarily the best thing for your body.
And it's basically sugar.
When you eat a piece of bread and you say,
Oh,
I'm going to have a piece of bread,
you're eating sugar,
your body processes,
it does almost the way as it would
process a simple sugar.
Yeah.
We don't have cereal,
bread,
pasta,
rice,
any of that stuff in our house.
What he rice eat a little bit of rice.
Wild Rice.
Yup.
Keen you you're have one was great.
Yeah.
So this is one of the few complex proteins like in plant form to where it has
basically all the amino acids and it was a seed,
right?
It's green.
We're green.
Yeah.
No.
And bread is one of the things that my,
and my wife is great with Diet.
She's very strict,
very disciplined.
And uh,
so when I look at a piece of bread,
it's like if I'm going to eat that,
that's a treat.
Like it's Kinda like having a piece of birthday cake or something.
It's really,
yeah.
Like,
if I go out for dinner or something,
it's a,
I'm going to have a piece of bread.
It's so exciting,
you know,
where's the most people eat that kind of stuff.
They think they're healthy and they,
cause I'm,
they're eating whole grain bread.
Yeah.
I don't,
it's,
it's a fascinating subject.
The subject of Diet.
It's really,
it's,
you are what you eat.
And that's such a stupid cliche for me to say,
but because it's been said so many times,
it's painful,
but it really is what it is.
Have you seen,
uh,
king corn?
Yes.
I mean that just proves that the guy was what he ate.
They were,
and they were made of their DNA was made of corn and yeah,
the carbon was based on corn when they did an analysis of their hair.
Um,
I love that documentary because these guys went into it pretty,
pretty,
you know,
they weren't aware.
They didn't really know what corn.
Okay,
let's find out what this is all about.
They bought an acre of corn or least an acre of corn.
This guy's farm,
grew it and watch the whole thing from putting the corn to the ground to
harvesting it and selling it and seeing where it goes after it's sold.
Amazing documentary and a stunning analysis of like where our culture is right
now when it comes to farm subsidies and how it affects every human being on this
planet.
And when they go to the supermarket and start finding all the different corn
ingredients that are on all these different products,
corn proteins and corn syrup and corn flour and corn,
this and that.
And like,
fuck yeah,
yeah.
Unless you're eating purely whole foods,
you're going to be eating corn and corn is not good.
Like your body doesn't digest Cornwell.
That's why you find corn kernels and your shit.
You know?
That's like,
it's really that simple.
And why is that in there?
Because your body didn't digest it.
Your body's like,
what is this your body like?
Basically spits it out the way it went in.
You swallow a kernel of corn or it'll come out like a marble,
you know?
I mean that's really,
that's your body telling you something.
Hey,
we're not,
this isn't,
what is this?
I don't even know what to do with it.
I'm wondering about that because you know corn on the cob and the summer,
I don't eat it anymore because it is so disgusting.
How dare you.
You put butter on it,
but you don't make comp gets buttered.
Damn.
It's so good.
It's a butter that makes things taste good.
We were in Costa Rica last.
You don't eat a stick of butter by itself.
Tastes like shit.
You know I don't buy that.
I think it's the butter on the corn.
Well,
if it's melted,
you dip something into it that would,
otherwise it helps lobster.
Yeah.
I hadn't lobster.
I had steak and lobster for Christmas.
We were on holidays and in Costa Rica they don't,
they don't butters.
Pretty precious there.
They don't give that stuff out.
They don't just turn the butter out.
Yeah.
So I had this steak in lifetime.
It treat myself.
It's Christmas dinner and they didn't bring me butter and I said,
sorry to be a pain in the ass,
but can I get some butter with the lobster?
They were like,
they looked at me like of this third world people.
That's why they don't have nuclear weapons because I don't even know what
they're doing.
We won't let them have it.
Can't even handle buttery flux.
That's why you go up to Maine.
If you want lobster,
that's where they make a real lobster.
Goddamn American lobster,
not just Costa Rican bullshit.
They don't even have claws.
This is unarmed pussy,
lobsters,
peace,
love and lobsters.
You go to Maine,
you get those cold water lobsters.
Oh,
that's the real lobster.
My friend that's,
they fly Maine lobsters all over the country.
You know.
Fuck yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
You don't want those.
They have California lobsters.
Like if you go to Malibu,
uh,
off the coast,
you'll see people right now,
cause it's lobster season.
They scuba dive for lobsters.
They go in the water and they've got their fucking goggles on and shit.
And they're looking for lobsters.
But there's a different lobster.
So lobster with no clause.
Some bitch ass pacifists lobster,
they don't taste as good.
You want the violent lobsters of Maine cold water,
angry,
beating the shit out of each other,
cotton off each other's fucking tentacles.
Those are the ones you capture it and there is so delicious.
They're like a sweet.
Those cold,
cold water lobster is Atlantic lobsters are his suite with butter.
The butter does help so much for the Diet.
It's butter.
Okay.
What about grass fed butter?
Yeah,
butter's great.
Has a great,
yeah,
it's fat.
We don't get enough fat in our diets.
That's really true.
Yeah,
I believe so.
What boat were fat,
so how does that work?
Well,
I know you're playing dead devil's advocate probably,
but you know you're so clever.
God Damn Canadians,
she wants to have a head.
It's a,
it's the sugar.
It's the sugar.
The sugar is this fast,
but we need fat in our diet.
Not to be fat.
We don't need to be fat,
but we need to eat fats.
Yeah.
For our cell membranes,
for our hormones.
Everything's made out of fat.
Everything good in her body's made out of fat.
Yeah,
like Avocados.
Even not even just animal fats.
There's a lot of good healthy coconut oil.
There's a lot of good healthy fats that we could use on a regular basis.
My wife talked me if an avocado in my backpack,
just freak out.
Some wife was never packed me up.
Fucking avocado on her life kind of.
I don't talk to her about that shit.
Do you eat game?
Do He game me?
There's so many guys.
I'm the only guy in my,
uh,
I play beer league hockey and I think I'm the only guy on our hockey team that
doesn't hunt.
So I got to get into this.
Would you get into hunting?
I'd love to.
I'm telling you,
man,
me and Steve Rinella been talking about doing a television show where we take
people out hunting that I've ever been hunting before.
The only problem
with that idea,
I don't have that much time.
And when I go out hunting,
I don't want to be go on hold in your hand,
Keith Webber.
I want to go out to shoot an animal,
but I can eat.
I'm going to have time to like show you how to shoot an animal.
So you're gonna have,
you're on your own.
That's what I'm saying.
Right.
Well and I think it seems like it is a weekly week long ordeal.
Oh yeah.
Well,
we just went for a week in Alaska and we struck out,
we didn't get anything,
so it's not always guaranteed.
This is my first strike out trip.
But,
uh,
I've,
every hunting trip I've been on,
it's been about a week and all of them up until this one had been successful.
But it's work,
man.
It's work.
Unless you want to go to a place where,
you know,
like you could go to a place that they have these ranches,
especially in Texas that are called high high fence ranches.
So the old,
it'd be x amount of acres.
A lot of them are huge,
like 10,000 plus acres,
but they're fenced in and there's animals in there for sure.
But it's all private property,
but it's kind of like a park,
you know?
I mean,
you know what I mean?
It's like once there's a fence,
I mean is it better than going to the grocery store and buying a steak from an
animal that lived in a pen?
Yes,
it is.
Most certainly because they are living in a very wild way there.
It's essentially what you would call fair chase.
There's 10,000 acres and these animals are living in this environment that is
absolutely natural.
They're not being fed.
There's not like,
you know,
the bell goes off at nine in the morning and the fucking the food pours out in
front of them.
It's not that they're just eating natural grasses and wanting to go wrong in
these natural environments,
but they're there for sure.
So it's Kinda like a stocked lake and some,
some ways that sounds pretty good,
but people don't have a problem with the stock lake,
but they do have a problem with a high fence hunting.
Hmm.
I think we feel like we have such an advantage already over animals that like to
have more of an advantage,
like to have them blocked in by an actual fence is kind of a pussy way of doing
it.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I could see that thought.
Hey,
I have friends that bow hunt,
uh,
which I find that's pretty respectable.
And uh,
that's actually how I hurt my shoulder.
I'm talking to you about getting Regena keen,
my shoulder,
right?
Yeah.
It's from pulling a boat too many times I could,
yeah,
that's good exercise isn't it?
It's,
it's,
well,
it's decent exercise,
but it's just repetitive stress.
I just,
I'm an idiot.
So I was doing it 150,
a hundred 150 times a day and you pull in between 80 and 90 pounds.
So I'm pulling 80 and 90 lbs.
I have two different bows and I'm doing it a hundred times a day plus.
So after awhile my shoulder was like,
fuck you stupid.
Like keep it getting us to do this when we're sore.
Stop.
Is that the shoulder that usually bugs you?
What doesn't usually bug me.
It's just started to bug me because of all the bow,
all the archery.
So I have a lighter bow.
Did I shoot with now too?
But archery is fun.
Just as far as like an exercise,
like for your mind,
like just to a zen sort of a thing to tune into that one spot you're trying to
hit.
Keep everything calm,
everything's together.
Tuned in like his shoe and let the Arrow,
everything's absolutely still just perfectly lined up.
Did she go,
I even inspired me at forget the guns.
Yeah.
Bow Hunting.
Bow Hunting for Moose.
How to make sure you shoot behind a tree though.
So the most charges while we circle the tree.
Yeah.
He just killed an elk.
He was,
yeah,
I couldn't believe it.
He borrowed a one of my mountain bikes to ride up there.
Hey,
slow pay.
He said,
why walk when I can borrow one of your bikes?
That's a smart dude.
Yeah.
But I think elk probably hear that bike.
Common core.
Like what the fuck is this guy doing?
Well,
he said what they do is they'll have the guy that's going to kill the thing in
sort of the danger area and then they'll have the guy calling it behind them.
Ah,
I see.
So it's like this thing is totally unsuspecting.
He's like,
what does that,
cause he thinks it's another male,
right?
Right.
Well,
either thinks it's another male or thinks it's a cow.
They,
um,
they called during what's called the Rut,
which is when the animals are all trying to get their sexy time in.
Right.
And they have this crazy noise.
If you never heard an elk bugle,
it's,
I've never heard it in real life.
I've heard cows,
they make a weird whistle.
I've heard that in real life.
But unless you're there during the spring or during the fall,
rather like a right around,
I think it's October ish,
like right around now.
Really is when they're,
they're running.
Yeah.
And when they're writing their,
they have this,
okay.
It's crazy noise that they make this bugle.
And the way you call them in is either you,
wow.
Yeah.
That's the real news.
A whale.
It does.
It's so crazy.
They're a majestic animal.
They really aren't majestic.
They're so fucking big.
There's like 1200 pounds,
some of them,
you know,
and that's so much meat.
I mean,
you shoot one of them mean you've got like essentially you've got a year's worth
of food.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Total renewable resource.
They're constantly having babies.
You know the huge herds of him all throughout Utah and Idaho and Colorado.
That's so cool.
What a fucking wild animal man.
And they,
they practice like the calls,
right?
They have like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Whistles.
All the hunters.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of different companies that make different whistles that,
but it's funny because hunters can actually tell the difference between someone
using a hunting call that sounds like an elk and an actual elks sound.
So a lot of hunters are convinced that elk,
like smart elk that had been around for many seasons,
they go,
you know what?
I'm not buying that one.
I fucking heard that before.
Last on Arrow went flying near my head the last time I came here.
That fucking sound,
you know,
some of them,
they sound pretty realistic.
And other ones,
they just sound like a call,
but it's enough.
All you have to do is just get them there.
So horny apparently when it's going on there,
they have hard ons and their dicks are like flopping against their stomach.
When they come out screaming,
bellowing and they just,
they're like,
fuck you bitch.
You know,
you better not be making that noise my neighborhood.
And they come running out and that's when he'd get them.
Cause otherwise like getting close enough to shoot him with an Arrow is really
difficult or sense of smells.
Insane.
They're hearing is insane.
They're always on the lookout and you got to get within,
you know,
less than 50 yards most of the time.
Yeah.
And they have,
don't they have smells that the hunter has a smell that he puts on them?
You can do that.
You can spray things on you.
They will help a little,
their sense of smells just so,
it's so powerful though that human beings can't even really conceptualize it.
I don't think.
Our idea of what a smell is like when they're getting like a fucking Internet
download pdf file of you,
when they smell you,
they're getting like,
oh this guy's eating hamburgers is drinking beer.
We gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
I smell gunpowder,
let's go.
You know,
they just bolt like they're getting like so much information from your smell.
Yeah.
We think of it as like,
oh,
he can smell me.
I think they're getting like a book on you.
You know?
I think they just fucking,
they get your whole life story and like go see a lot of people.
Um,
the also eat grass and um,
vegetables only like a few guys I've talked to like the week of the hunt,
so their breath is the breath of a vegetation eating animal instead of like
someone who eats like a lot of meat and you're making burps that they,
he smells like rotten meat coming out of your face.
Like,
oh,
I think I know what this guy's up to.
It's true,
isn't it though?
I don't think you're supposed to eat that much meat.
Well I think if you were going near them and it would totally make sense.
Yeah.
If you were trying to track an animal that's worried about you eating it,
I would think that you would try to,
if you,
if you eat a lot of vegetables,
your breath would be that of a something that eats vegetables.
So they say that that's like the big giveaways,
your breath.
Some people even eat like spruce needles,
they'll choose spruce needles while they're out in the field because a,
it'll sort of mask the natural smells inside their breath.
I never heard that.
That makes total sense though.
It does about me bro.
Making total sense all day.
So you're your buddies and your hockey league,
they all a hunt.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they have.
They offered to take you.
They have,
yeah,
I got to take them.
It's just,
it worries me because it sounds like a bit of an alcoholic,
a paradise made.
Does it?
Yeah.
Like it sounds like they,
it is.
They do usually kill animals.
They're pretty good.
Like I think they do this every year since they were kids,
so they do a drunk as fuck.
Well I think they drink at night and after it's over.
Yeah,
I think they hunt all day and then at night they just,
it sounds like the,
uh,
they drink more than,
but they're pretty hot.
Yeah.
They're uh,
they're good.
Good Group of guys.
They're the,
uh,
Elberton blue collar Albert
archetype.
Well,
there's so much game up there in Alberta.
You guys have some of the biggest bucks like as far as like deer in the world.
Yeah.
It'll giant hundred pound white tails.
You have these enormous meal,
deers,
huge Moose bear.
You have black bear all over the place up there.
It's like a paradise of game.
Well,
even the city we live in is,
uh,
I see deer every day in my backyard.
Like it's,
they're like rabbits.
Really?
Yeah.
Just like white tailed deer.
Shoot.
Well,
how's things Keith?
Whenever I thought about it,
but I don't think you're allowed to in city limits.
No.
Well how,
what is like,
when you say city limits?
What city?
Red here.
Yeah.
You could shoot him in red deer.
Okay.
Name Red deer to the name of the city.
You're allowed to.
I read that.
If your finger yards over a certain size and you have a bow and Arrow,
but you probably get away with it.
Yeah,
you could.
You could.
The problem is if the deer hops,
the fence goes your neighbor's yard and it's fucking tits up,
bleeding out on his lawn and he's like,
Hey Keith,
wherever you fucking Dick head,
I'm like,
you don't shoot a fucking animal in my neighborhood.
I got to clean this lawn.
Um,
if they have,
they've invited you to come along,
would you have to like take a firearm safety thing or anything up there?
You have to do that.
Like take a hunter's education.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
And I don't think it's that big of a deal.
It sounds,
and my dad has a bunch of rifles and stuff that he doesn't use,
so what the fuck Keith,
get it,
get it crack and it's the healthiest meat as far as like,
it's also the most ethically you're,
you're so connected to whatever you're eating.
You shoot a deer and you cut the deer up and you eat it.
You,
you were 100% completely invested and connected with that animal as opposed to
that weird disconnect that you get,
especially when you eat like Baloney,
you know,
have I got Bologna Sandwich?
Like what?
Hey,
what even is that,
like,
what steps have been taken to turn this into this perfectly symmetrical round
slice of whatever the fuck it is that used to be alive thing.
I remember the Bologna when I was a kid,
they used to have like the little Alpha Getty's embedded into it.
I don't know if he ever,
what's an Alpha Getty?
You never had that.
It's like,
I don't know what that means.
Alpha Getty.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's a like a can of,
uh,
like pasta with,
you know,
the tomato sauce and the various letters of the alphabet and,
Yep.
Oh good.
He goes,
yeah,
like spaghettios with,
with letters.
Yeah.
Alpha Yeti.
Forgetting poor Canada for Canada makes me sad.
No,
doesn't,
I mean this,
we have something similar.
What is that called?
It's not spaghettios,
what is it?
Alphabet,
alphabet soup.
I don't know.
Yeah,
there's alphabet soup for sure.
That's like that.
But yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
I think we're getting,
it always makes me,
it always makes I die,
but I still people,
I still see people eating Bologna.
Is it bad for you?
I don't think it's good.
It's definitely not good for you.
Now that's the one thing with the Paleo and that they're big on Bacon.
Right,
right,
right.
And I,
I love,
I'm sure we all love Bacon,
but I don't think should eat that much
of it.
Like I'm leery about that concept of,
uh,
that much sodium and nitrate.
But I guess it's depends on the type of bacon.
I guess there's probably Bacon out there that you can have natural beg and it
doesn't last as long.
But I,
from what I understand,
there's certain natural nitrates in like sea salt and celery.
Celery apparently is naturally high in nitrates and salary is not bad for you.
So I guess is it just,
Oh,
I have to fucking have Rhonda Patrick on soon have to ask her about nitrates.
I don't understand that.
Yeah.
It's supposed to produce carcinogens or something like that.
Allegedly.
And that what the TSA always fines on people.
Nitrates give your high nitrates we to pull you over in this room.
Yeah.
Like if you,
uh,
have been on a farm,
that's one of the things they say.
Like if you,
uh,
well here's a funny story.
When Brian First started working for me,
actually I think before Brian was even working for me,
he was selling a laptop.
He had a laptop and he put it up for sale on the,
on the message board.
And I purse,
I private messaged them,
I said,
I need a laptop,
like a second laptop for work stuff.
It was a windows laptop.
And I said,
I'll buy it.
So he sold me the laptop,
sent it to me,
and then I took it like from the moment I got it from,
I took it on the road and uh,
I put it in my bag and I went through the airport and they immediately flagged
it and they pulled me aside and they said,
your,
your laptop is testing positive for explosives.
And I went,
what?
What do you mean?
And they were like,
well,
have you ever been to a farm recently?
And all I could think of is that motherfucker cranking me.
He puts a fucking gun powder all over the laptop and then sold it to me.
But it just,
it had,
for some reason,
it tested for trace amounts of nitrogen and traits or whatever the fuck it was.
And that's what they find on explosives.
Well,
they,
the,
you know,
you can have fertilizer bombs like what they used at Oklahoma City apparently
was a fertilizer bomb.
Remember that Timothy Mcveigh thing?
Supposedly there's a lot of controversy and conspiracy theories regarding that
incident.
They believe it wasn't just that it was other bombs plans in the bill,
whatever,
I don't know.
But you can make a fertilizer bomb.
It's pretty potent.
So that's what they're worried about when they test your laptop and they find
that shit fertilizers,
they're bombs now,
you know,
manure,
nitrates,
methane,
like that shit.
Like your farts on fire.
You could also blow up people's Shit
like in fight club where they,
uh,
took the soap or the human fat and meat soap and bombs out of that.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Right.
Yeah,
that works.
Do you ever see that video where that whale is a beached whale and his body's
rotting and it explodes?
We will see that.
If you're sitting there like never see,
oh my God,
it's fucking crazy.
See if he can find a Jamie probe the videos.
See Keith could watch it.
Yeah.
You know your body's,
uh,
when this whales bodies rotting on the beach,
I guess it just comes to some boiling.
Were they moving
it when it exploded?
There are trying to and they couldn't.
It just took too long and it fucking exploded.
Oh,
there was one where they were taking it in a truck.
You remember that?
They were,
they had a beached whale and they'd pick the beach whale up and they were moving
it and as they were moving and it exploded literally like a bomb.
But there's one that blew up on purpose too,
I think because it had to get rid of the body and then,
yeah,
I don't want to see that one.
I want to see natural zone bomb.
That'll happen with wildlife too.
I remember when I was a kid,
we lived out in the middle of nowhere and uh,
uh,
there people would leave the animals in the ditch and after a couple of weeks
the stomach would just expand like a,
like almost like you're blowing a bubble from bubblegum.
So I remember being a kid,
I could never chew bubblegum cause my mom would be so disgusted because it would
remind her of this big sack of a stomach ripping out of this animal's body.
Hey cause all the little lab bacteria and everything go to work once the animal
dies and it just like swells up into this big.
And I vaguely remember seeing an animal with like a big pink bubble sticking out
of its gut.
Why?
Cause if you don't get an animal right away,
like a deer and elk or something,
it'll starts rotting little rotten and like the stomach is fairly thin,
their skin.
So it'll actually start to expand.
That makes me sad that some people don't eat the organs of the animals.
They kill it.
So it's so wasted.
I mean,
ultimately it's all going to get eaten by bacteria and other life forms anyway,
and you know,
scavengers it will all go to use.
If you just leave it there,
it'll go to use.
Yeah.
But the Oregons or some of the best parts of the body,
like as far as like eating,
like eating the liver and eating the heart is fantastic and very nutritious.
Really good for you.
Do you live eat liver?
Yeah.
I love liver livers.
Delicious and liver off a deer like a fresh deer liver that you just shot is so
good.
It's incredible how good it is.
When we were in Montana,
we,
uh,
we shot these deer and I shot a deer and within two hours we were cooking the
liver over a campfire and it was just unbelievable.
We were just eating and called all my God,
this is incredible.
And then we fry it up the heart and we ate the heart the same way,
like right over the campfire.
It's incredible.
If you find anything,
caution,
warning,
warning.
Some viewers may find a sister of man's man.
Those,
those viewers are pussies.
Here we go.
Let's pitch.
Go see what the fuck this is.
Are we going to get flagged on Youtube for this?
Okay,
here we go.
Look at this.
They're carving into this whale and as they're carving into it,
it's Oh God,
look at that.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
The guy runs like a bitch.
Yeah.
What'd you think?
It's going to blow up again,
sir.
Look how far it's shot.
Splattered all over the wall.
It's Charlotte again,
Jamie.
Okay,
that's crazy.
So he is digging into it
to relieve pressure,
I guess.
Oh,
what a weird fucking job.
What do you do?
Well,
you know when whales die,
I go and I cut in that looked like it would fuck you up.
That's not just a little explosion.
That's like a serious ferocious explosion.
Boom.
Like if you were standing right in front of that,
you're going down,
bitch,
you going to get hurt.
Imagine if that's how he died.
How'd you die?
Well,
when I was beached whale can and cut into it and it fucking blew up in my face.
Took my hat off.
Here I am.
And having
feeling bad
when your friends go hunting,
they give you me.
Um,
no,
actually you don't,
I shouldn't say that.
Uh,
cause it's customary after a beer league hockey game to indulge in meat type
snacks,
cheese,
a pref,
preferably going out to a local pub to have chicken wings,
beer,
rum and cokes,
things like that.
Um,
but there are times when we're in a place where they don't have a good pub and
outcomes the beef jerky and everyone's really,
cause I think they,
they use a lot of them,
the animal,
uh,
to make beef jerky out of.
So,
and everyone's very proud of their secret recipe,
so.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Amazing.
That is a cool thing about,
um,
a lot of hunters that they get really into cooking because they're,
they're so connected with the meat that they get themselves,
they start getting into like being a chef and like Steve [inaudible],
he's a big time chef.
He loves cooking food.
The new Max.
Do you cook your own meals?
Do you have like,
um,
like very specific recipes that you follow as far as like healthy eating and we
don't ring from exercise.
We,
uh,
we eat a lot of soup.
Soup.
Yeah.
Even for breakfast wheeler.
Why Soup?
Uh,
it's a really easy way to get a lot of vegetables into your diet.
Um,
and we use these animal bro.
Like we,
we've got a few local sort of grass fed places that you can get the soup bones
from.
Uh,
so we'll boil these bones for a day or two,
just get all that Gel and everything off him.
Throw that in the,
the concoction of boiled vegetables.
And,
uh,
and according to my wife,
this is good to have something warm in the stomach in the morning cause our
stomach fire,
again,
this is all terminology,
uh,
is it's our stomachs.
Our digestive enzymes aren't as active in the morning.
So if you eat this soup,
it sort of gets things going in the right direction.
So,
and then with my job,
I don't like to take a lunch break.
I like to just blast straight on through for eight hours.
So,
uh,
I just throw it in a Vitamix or what's your job?
What's your regular job?
A physiotherapist.
So you work with are people that are injured and things along those lines?
Yeah.
So I go from person to person and I don't have a ton of time in between to have
a big meal and I find that makes me tired anyway.
So tear fall the warrior diet?
Uh,
yeah.
You know,
I did that
for a while just because it was convenient because I didn't have to eat all day
and then,
but I found I pigged out a little bit too much at night,
so yeah.
But I think there's something to that,
especially after reading,
eat,
stop,
eat.
I think it was Rhonda Rousey was fallen off for awhile.
I know she's found anymore,
but she was essentially,
she would eat like berries and some fruits during the day.
But from primarily her main meal was one meal at night.
She would work out all day like a beast and then she would eat this.
You know,
I think,
like I said,
some berries and some,
some light things and fruit juices and things during the day,
but her primary meal was a nighttime meal and she was having some great benefits
from it.
Yeah,
I think it,
you know what?
I think there's something to that and it's,
again,
it flies in the face of my bodybuilder.
Friends,
they want to eat the six meals per day.
Yeah.
And then take a protein shake in the middle of the night.
And I've also heard people say that when you eat many times a day,
that somehow or another,
it stimulates your metabolism.
But I don't,
I don't know what evidence there are or is that,
yeah,
I don't think there is.
There's so many different fucking schools of thought when it comes to diet and
exercise.
I mean,
remember when you were kids?
When we were kids,
they had the pyramid,
the food pyramid,
and the bottom was all grains.
I was like,
you need carbohydrates.
And now it's like,
hey,
did that bottom part,
the foundation?
Throw it out.
We don't need that at all.
Like what?
That's everything.
The grains are everything.
You need the rains?
No.
Well then there must be something to that six meals a day because I've seen a
lot of people get like really good physiques on that.
So I dunno.
I think the idea is that when you eat a lot of small meals that your body's
never working on stored food cause it's constantly getting new food.
And so that's what stimulates your body to go,
look,
we don't need all this fat cause we're getting food every fucking two hours.
So let's just get rid of all the fat and just live off this food.
Yeah.
It must be something like that.
Then you get into the hormones and things like that and it gets so complicated.
No wonder people get confused.
But do you do anything specifically like exercise wise to try to stimulate
growth hormone or testosterone?
Cause they say like really explosive exercises like Steve Maxwell is a,
a big proponent of that.
Like very specific exercises that are designed to stimulate your hormonal
system.
Yeah.
I,
that's why I love the double kettlebells.
Uh,
and that's my idea for the next video.
It's taken me a long time to figure out how to implement that and make,
make it so that you could actually have a video and follow along with two
kettlebells and uh,
uh,
which was what we were going to experiment with.
But your shoulder was sore.
So good Shah shoulder.
It has actually not bad.
Like I can do a lot of things with it.
I just don't,
I know too many people that have had shoulder surgery and that's a big one man
because it's such a complex joint.
It articulates in such weird ways.
It's so much different than just the hinge joint of the elbow or the knee or the
shoulder moves.
So I don't,
I don't fuck around with shoulder.
If I have any shoulder injuries,
I treat it right away.
The shoulder blade actually just look scapula.
It actually floats on our rib cage.
Like it's not actually attached to anything.
Muscles like the only thing that ti detaches are shoulder to our skeleton is
the,
this joint here,
these your collarbone.
It just connects everything.
It's amazing.
It's a very complex joint and it's not so good at getting beat up.
And then when,
when people start having like Forrest Griffin for me,
UFC fighter,
you can't even brush his teeth his right hand,
like literally can't brush his teeth his right hand,
he has to brush his teeth was left just from fucking shoulder up just from
fighting through pain.
Right.
That's a big one.
Cain Velasquez,
another perfect example.
UFC heavyweight champion.
I mean he's actually talked about it.
He's got such a high tolerance for pain because he's so tough.
It have an injury and I'll just work through it and then wind up needing surgery
cause he just tears his shit apart.
Yeah,
yeah.
That is,
they're just big balls of scar tissue.
And that's,
I see that every day,
probably to a lesser extent than these guys,
but to a smaller extent and just people that sit at a desk all day using a mouse
and the tissues actually adaptively short and it start to calcify.
So then they go and try to take up an exercise program or something and all of a
sudden they're tearing this tissue so they're always in pain.
So what's your thoughts on deep tissue massage,
rolfing and things along those lines?
I think that's what's made our clinic sort of a successful is we're one of the
few physios that that's what we specialize in versus some places they'll use a
lot of machines and fancy stuff like that.
And it's a,
it doesn't work as well.
It's just grabbing onto somebody and breaking that scar tissue out of there.
Especially if you,
they know what they're doing.
Man,
I've had people work on me that are good and I've had people work on me that
aren't so good and the really good people,
they can make a profound change in the way you feel.
Like if you have like a tense back or kinked up things or like a constant
reoccurring injury,
you'd be amazed at how much of it is just like a bound up area that can be
broken down.
Nothing a Graston.
I started doing that recently where they use metal.
Yeah.
Sort of a rolfing with like metal tools,
right?
Not,
it doesn't feel good.
No,
but it feels great after it's done.
Yeah.
Well you're getting in and that's,
that tissue is hypersensitive like 24 seven it's just full of lactic acid and
those no c receptors,
those pain receptors are just constantly sensitized.
So,
and that stuff just stays in there.
It's like tartar on your teeth unless someone gets in there and blast that out
of there for you.
It's amazing though that you can do that,
that you,
you the,
the human body,
you can actually change the way it feels to the person by just digging into the
muscle tissue and breaking it down is elbowing into it and pulling and
stretching.
Like I have this guy who does,
he's brutal man.
I mean he's,
he's,
it's unbelievably painful,
but when it's over,
everything just feels like completely relaxed.
Like all these tents areas and I got to think that's got to be tremendous for
healing.
Oh yeah.
And what's happened is the Fascia has healed together.
So you're dealing with a
muscle fibers that are,
they've healed,
they're healthy,
but it's that covering around them.
It's literally glued together,
calcified together and like get fibrotic state.
So if you can find somebody that works that to the point where it actually
breaks apart,
it feels amazing and it'll continue.
It'll allow you to keep training and not keep reinjuring that spot.
So yeah,
that's where it,
rolfing actually came from.
That woman who created Rolfing,
I believe her son had cerebral palsy and she created it to manipulate a soft
tissue to give him more range of motion,
give him more,
more um,
a pain free life.
Yeah.
It works like a charm.
So when you do that stuff,
how often do you do it?
Uh,
what like on other people or on yourself?
How often you have it done?
I try for once every couple of weeks.
That's it.
Yeah.
Really?
Cause if you get rid of it really thoroughly,
uh,
I've gone through spells where I've had sort of two treatments a week for
awhile,
but once you get that crap out of there,
it's gone.
Like I,
I had a job tree planting for eight summers while I went through university.
And uh,
it's a very one sided job.
It's,
you got the shovel in your right hand,
you're kicking the tree and with your right foot,
you're planning literally thousands of trees a day and you're walking up
mountains with these bags,
that trees and it's uh,
it's an intense job but you get paid per tree.
So there's a lot of incentive there to work your butt off.
I said,
why not just switch sides?
It's really,
it's,
it's almost like a writing or something.
When you get good with that shovel,
you can like weasel in,
in between rocks or find like the little patch of soil.
You look for a little blade of grass to slam that shovel into cause you're,
it's all about economy.
Now.
I do know a few guys that messed up their dominant hand and had to learn with
the left hand and they actually did after about a week of making no money,
they actually started doing the brain almost just like the brain plasticity,
hey kicked in and they're like,
oh my God.
So from then on it and they could like take all the trees out of this bag,
switch hands and take.
So I always thought that'd be a good idea to do but I never did.
Yeah,
they say that when you use the dominant side only on any sort of like a,
like Steve Maxwell had a,
uh,
he had a comparison when it was coming to a people that work in football,
the kickers that these kickers are always kicking with the right side and that
they were really getting all these weird back pains and all these strains and
the left leg and all they had to do to get rid of it.
We start kicking with the left side so they kick an equal number of times with
the left side.
And then it was also discovered that when you exercise your non dominant hand,
like if you're doing something with your nondominant hand,
it actually makes the dominant hand skill set better.
Like your understanding of whatever you're trying to do,
whether it's like executing punches or doing martial arts techniques or
something along those lines.
When you deal with your nondominant side,
it actually makes your dominant side better.
Yeah.
There's even studies,
uh,
taking people in a cast and
taking their other arm and lifting weights while this arm's in a cast and he
found at the end of four weeks or six weeks or however long it takes those
muscles to atrophy,
they've actually lost,
lost almost no muscle mass.
Well I don't even move that arm.
It's crazy.
Even people visualizing working out without RM while it's in a cast shows
significant improvements in muscle atrophy.
Really?
Yeah.
Visualizing exercise that will win.
That would make sense.
I gas cause your body like thinks it's going to do something and so it like
fires up those receptors.
No,
it doesn't make sense.
Wait.
It's hard to believe.
Right.
Things like watching sports or make you better at sports.
I get it.
Process probably does though a little bit.
Yeah.
You in mirror,
you mirror what the athletes are doing and you also,
you sort of,
uh,
I think martial arts like watch,
it's very important if you're in a gym to watch like the best guys watch like
the really high level guys kick and punch and do you know Jujitsu moves because
you see what it should look like.
Yeah.
What itch and it gives you like a high level to aspire to.
It's uh,
I have a theory about we're big on the NHL in Canada.
We love hot.
I never heard that.
Canadians like hockey.
Yeah,
we love it.
You don't say we're actually going to the La Kings game on Sunday.
My son is just over the moon.
Um,
but anyway,
I think that hockey nowadays is so much better because they've got that screen
to look at.
They look at me please constantly,
every time you see them looking up at what they just did.
And I think I'm not going to do that again.
I think there must be something to that.
Cause hockey nowadays.
I watched the 1987 Canada Cup where Canada beat Russia and yeah,
I mean these guys were,
this is Wayne Gretzky and Mario Lemieux and the best hockey players and it
looked brutal compared to,
uh,
what it is nowadays.
My way,
I'll just slower a slower for one thing,
the shots were weaker.
The it just a slower game.
It was almost like watching one of our Bierly games compared to what it is
nowadays.
Not Crazy.
Yeah.
But that's how it is with sports when,
you know,
there's always enough,
there's always innovation.
There's always the training methods are expanding and getting better and where
there's the understanding of the human body,
that's kind of a unique thing about what you do because exercise and training
and strength and conditioning training,
it's,
it's a constantly evolving business and a constantly evolving discipline.
That's so interesting.
There's so much information out there and it's just,
I love reading it.
It's so interesting.
If you were going to like save someone like a Jason McDonald or saved like Rory
Mcdonald's,
some MMA athlete,
a high level athlete came to you and uh,
wanted to improve their strength and conditioning,
how would you approach like training someone like that?
Well,
you know,
I'd look at what,
cause these guys are such high level athletes,
I would look at what they're lacking when they feel like they're lacking,
like maybe something in their
ground game that's lacking.
Or maybe they want more power with their strikes and,
and give them just enough to enhance what they're doing,
but not so much that it's causing them injury or taking away from what they're
doing.
Cause I think there's,
overtraining is probably quite prevalent nowadays.
It's very prevalent.
It's Ah,
it's all overtraining is also prevalent because there's this mindset that more
is better.
Yeah.
And that you just need to be tougher.
He just need to keep pushing,
keep pushing and more is better.
But if your body is not recovering,
you're not doing any good by keeping going,
you were actually doing damage because you're giving your body more of a war.
It's like that you have to have that fine line.
You don't want to give your body like a low low workload where it doesn't
actually reach a high level of intensity and conditioning,
but you don't want to give it so much that it never reaches a,
a period of recovery that is always constantly dealing with a deficit.
Yeah.
And I think these guys are always riding that thin edge so you have to be really
careful before you start integrating
something.
So if you have an athlete that came to you and said,
listen man,
I'm,
my power's fine.
It's not my issue.
My issue is conditioning.
I want to be able to have a full gas tank from the first minute of the first
round.
I want to be able to fight like that at the fifth round in the final minute.
Like,
what,
what do you,
uh,
what do you have them do for things like,
yeah,
I would,
I would recommend kettlebells,
like,
and that the type of training scenario that I've shown on the videos,
because I think it teaches you to like,
you know,
you do 10 thrusters per site in there,
you're winded,
but you have that little bit of a wiggle room where you can switch hands with
the kettle bell.
He can take a few deep breaths and then keep going.
And it's almost like you learn those respiratory muscles almost learning.
You learn how to like,
control that fatigue and keep breathing even through fatigue.
And meanwhile,
you're still doing the exercises so you're still exerting yourself.
But I love that kind of true.
I think that carries over so nicely to where you're maybe on the ground and
you're,
you're gassed and to get that quick recovery back.
So what about like flexibility,
training and range of motion training?
Do you,
uh,
and those kinds of things?
Well like to,
in order to do an overhead squat,
you have to be pretty flexible,
you know,
and to do a terrific job.
In what way?
Well,
to get deep,
flexible.
Yeah.
Look,
you have quads,
I guess.
Well you need your,
uh,
your,
doctors.
Hey,
you need to almost be able to do,
like,
I think if you did enough overhead squats like nice and deep,
uh,
you'd be able to get close to,
of doing a partial split.
That's funny cause it never that issue.
Um,
because of,
uh,
I did a lot of stretching when I was young,
so I've always been pretty flexible.
So I never felt like any flexible,
uh,
any,
um,
uh,
strain on my flexibility.
And when I do an overhead squats,
I would've never thought of it as a flexibility exercise.
Well,
and I'm busy working with people that are,
have never done anything,
so I can see how their squats improves so quickly.
Uh,
because a loaded up muscle will always stretch better.
So I can see people,
their first Kettlebell class doing these,
squats it or not that good.
And then after a couple sessions it's like,
Whoa,
where did that come from?
It opening up and opening up.
He was sitting up and that's what I,
that's,
that is one of my favorite exercise overhead squats.
Cause if you're not keeping those hips open and you're not doing your stretching
and you're not doing your strengthening,
that's a hard exercise.
That's like,
uh,
that's uh,
one of those exercises that tells you,
Oh yeah,
my programs on point.
It's good.
Right?
Yeah.
That's a really unique exercise too because it's so difficult to keep your arms
overhead and hold the weight up and drop all the way down when you're asked,
touches your heels and then straightened back up again.
It's such a core stabilization exercise.
Yup.
And you can tell people with weak cores because a,
they'll always get a cramp in the opposite side where they're,
if they're holding the kettle bell in their left hand,
their right quadratus lumborum will just seize up on them.
And so they haven't learned yet how to integrate the hip flexors and the
abdominals into getting that nice,
almost like your own weight training belt in the front.
So their QL takes all the load and that's probably how they go through life.
Right.
Every time they bend over to pick up groceries,
they're is just doing all the work and they're not,
I don't ever use weightlifting belts.
No,
I don't.
You know,
I had a trainer once that told me,
he goes,
if you need a weight lifting belt,
your w lift in too much weights.
Yeah.
Well you should do is just strengthen your back and your stomach muscles.
And uh,
I sort of took that to heart and I've never been a big heavyweight guy anyway.
I don't really lift that much heavyweight,
like the heaviest weight.
I lift a 70 pound kettle bells.
Yeah.
I just do one in each hand and I do most of my workouts like that.
Yeah,
that's a lot.
I mean that and just the leverage that those kettlebells provided,
they're trying to pull you forward.
That's a lot of weight.
It's my favorite is kettle bell squats with a 70 in each hand.
It's just you,
you're just so much,
so much like stabilization work when you're doing those things.
And I feel like when I,
I'm consistent and I do those once a week and I do it on a weekly basis for like
several months.
I just feel a big difference when I'm going to do like martial arts techniques.
I just feel a big difference in my ability to keep up the intensity like deep
into the browns.
Yeah.
To do those.
You're tensing everything.
Okay.
Uh,
you cannot relax for one minute.
It's a such a great,
so have you done double thrusters with maybe a lighter weight?
Yeah,
you have done double thrusters.
I love those.
Those and uh,
I mean I love to combine the double clean with the squat and I kind of got this
id off a trainer named Dan John,
you might've heard of him but he's into barbell complexes.
And so I've sort of taken a few of his ideas in order to length and note that
that set that you're using with it,
cause you get gas in a hurry with a double kettlebells.
So one of his favorite things is you do one clean one squat,
two cleans two squats up to five and doing that with two 24 hours is when you
get to like that five cleans and your,
you've already been like holding those kettlebells,
but it gives you just enough of a break that you can kind of get that last five
24 is a,
what does it,
52 pounds.
50 something pounds.
This kilograms pound conversions.
The funny thing is poohed like one pooed and two pood a come on.
What is it?
Who gives you 16 kilos?
I don't care.
Pounds.
America.
Eagles.
Yeah,
they two cars.
Pounds.
They switched us over to metric when I was about 10 years old.
They tried when I was in high school and they were giving it to us,
but nobody,
everybody was like whatever.
They tried for awhile,
they tried with soccer and they tried with the metric system from work.
Either one of them work soccer big in Canada.
It's getting bigger.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah and I think
partly because it's not that expensive,
completely hockey's expensive to play.
Well,
we were in Alaska this weekend.
My friend Martin who were up there,
he knows a lot about running and one of the things he was talking about was that
runners,
they're,
they're actually,
um,
there's a lot of people that believe that running and stretching,
it's like it's not necessary for runners to stretch.
Yep.
And even the world champion,
uh,
I think the top three guys in the world for triathlon right now,
and these are the guys that are doing the iron man distance.
They don't,
uh,
they admit to not stretching and the one guy's even a physiotherapist and no
stretching.
No,
I was
confusing to me.
I always thought that range of motion was like super important and it's
stretched.
Muscles were healthy muscles.
Yeah.
I just took a course from Stuart Mcgill,
I don't know if you've heard of him.
He's a Canadian guy,
but he's actually world-renown now.
And he wrote the book low back disorders a few years ago,
but he was the first guy.
He's actually a mechanical engineer.
And so what he's doing is a hooking electrodes like deep needles into people,
so as muscles and putting a trans force transducers on their actual spinal bones
and doing studies and he works on animals too.
And he's taking these exercises that we've given and he's actually measuring the
force that the muscles produce compared to the sheer in force in the compressive
force when we're doing these different exercises.
And from all of his research,
he's finally been sort of indicated like a lot of people when he first came out,
like there used to be a thing in physio where if you want your back to be
strong,
pull your belly button back to your backbone.
That's the best thing you can do cause it's going to engage the transverse
abdominis.
And he uh,
he blew that theory out of the water,
the transverse abdominis.
Actually we'll co contract when you take,
do that Valsalva maneuver when you're at the bottom of a squat and you come up
that,
that transverse abdominis,
it's almost like the rotator cuff will contract really hard if you make a tight
fist and do that.
So,
um,
anyway,
I'm getting off.
No,
please go out.
He blew it out of the water.
How so?
Well,
he really,
he realized that the transverse abdominis doesn't engage by tensing up here.
Your sphincter muscles a year.
You're black and you're pulling your belly belly button back.
It doesn't.
Hmm.
So,
and I,
they,
I think it came,
there was a study in Australia many years ago where they were doing an
ultrasound studies of people's,
so us muscles and they found it.
There was some,
so s and multifidus activation,
when you pull,
did the specific exercise [inaudible] police pulling the belly button back
towards your spine.
So,
so don't do that if you lift heavy.
Hmm.
So what should you do?
Just tighten up everything and Chitin posture.
Yes.
And tighten everything up.
Like they,
they call it breathing against the shield.
Uh,
or that don't suck in don't second.
That's sucking Adams isn't a weird though.
Would things like become common practice?
Then it turns out there were horse shit then everybody sort of abandons him.
Yeah.
In the,
you know,
but a lot of these things,
they all kind of prove if you'd have done some lifting,
what you kind of knew.
Like it just feels unnatural I think to like to pull your belly button back to
your spine.
If I'm doing yoga it feels right.
But if I'm lifting a heavy weight,
I want to,
you know,
tense up and get everything tight.
Right.
If you're doing yoga and you're doing those crazy breath things like you're
seeing Hixon Gracie's choke,
they were sending documentary.
No,
no.
How dare you,
you need to give that documentary right now.
And he does these crazy breathing exercises where,
you know,
he's like sucking his stomach in like all the way and moving it around like back
and forth.
You ever seen anybody do that?
I guess like you can cure constipation with that kind of thing really.
Or x locks a cup of coffee,
you can get crazy.
Yeah.
But I guess they can actually tie it.
You fucking,
but yeah,
I guess they can actually manipulate the waste products through the large
intestine and using their own abdominal muscles kind of makes sense.
You know,
you're pushing everything around,
you know,
it kind of seems like it would aid in digestion.
You know,
some people have this idea that you should eat like I'm smoothies in the morning
because smoothies like vegetable smoothies especially,
they're sort of lube up the pathway and then everything calming afterwards,
we'll have a,
an easy ride through the,
through the body's digestive system that that sounds feasible.
Yeah.
So why doesn't the stretching getting back to that story.
So he's all about the concept of super stiffness.
It's thing,
it's a term he might have coined,
but he's with athletes,
he's all about having the core stiff so that,
and I don't mean stiff where you can't pick you up your wallet or something,
but stiff to the point where it's always sort of all these abdominal and
postural muscles are on high alert so that when you do throw a punch or
something there,
they kick in all at once.
And he claims that from his studies,
excessive stretching of the core and the hips and the shoulders,
you lose that nice a tightness,
you lose that,
that nice normal sort of resiliency between the core in the extremities.
That's interesting.
But,
well the only thing that I would take issue with is that I think that a lot of
power comes from the range of motion and the flexibility.
Like especially when it comes
to kicking.
Yeah.
Like that's all.
Like whipping the body around like the,
there's a lot of power involved and having a a long range of motion.
Well,
and his thing is,
uh,
your course should be stiff,
but if you are in a kicking sport,
you need to have the,
the hips,
the hips need to be,
your core is a big Po.
If your core is stiff.
It seems like the more back flexibility that you have,
the more you can execute things with less resistance.
Yeah.
I think it's,
he's,
he's all about having that,
it's like a natural weight belt around.
Yeah.
Your hips.
And what sport does he engage in?
Well,
I think he,
he has worked,
he did say he has worked with some mixed martial artists.
Hmm.
I wonder what would happen if he worked with a mixed martial artist that was
like kicking specialists like a Machida or an Anderson silver or something like
that.
Like wonder if they would change their tune if they saw like how much
flexibility is necessary to pull off certain things like we'll kicks,
right.
You know,
things along those lines where your whole body's like moving in a very flow.
Anything that where you're resisting and it just like tension and,
yeah.
Well
there is,
um,
I guess maybe he's advocating not excessive flexibility in the trunk.
Like he's bigger on having this nice core control.
Uh,
but I don't think they're mutually exclusive.
I don't think so.
Can you have like a strong core and still a flexible?
I think so.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
he just doesn't like excessive stretching.
It seems to me that there's different requirements at different sports have like
what,
what you would need to be a very good shot putter.
You need a completely different set of physiological skills or strengths to be,
you know,
a Jujitsu player or you know,
a judo person or a karate master,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's like,
it's,
it's almost like the people who are training you have to be skilled in those
areas.
Yeah,
I agree.
And uh,
like I,
I don't think anyone doing sort of bodywork and soft tissue work,
I think they should all have some sort of foundation in some type of weight
training or some type of exercise where they're going through those same
processes themselves.
Because then I think it gives you a really nice and neat and understanding of
what you're dealing with.
When you get a person on your table,
you're like,
oh,
I can relate to that.
You know?
Do you do sports specific DVDs?
I mean,
I know you're do,
you've done how many DVDs so far?
Just those two.
The two extreme kettlebell workouts,
which are my favorite dude,
they're awesome things.
They really are my favorite because you're in fucking shape.
I mean,
you,
you do it along with everybody.
Like there's no faking that.
And the intensity is absolutely real.
Yeah.
You know,
the first video,
it's an interesting story,
but,
uh,
I'm,
I'm a bit of a procrastinator and,
uh,
so we were in Mexico when we filmed that one and we actually,
I had to walk forever to find a part of the beach or there's not a ton of people
around.
And so I had my backpack on.
And you just to get the Kettlebell to Mexico was a hard yeah,
right.
It's like,
what is this thing you want to take this,
you know,
and it was fortunate it was 20 kilograms and that's what they kind of allowed on
the plane was that 45 pounds,
44 pounds,
84 or something like that.
And so,
uh,
I had my backpack,
so I just logged my backpacking into the fragile luggage,
but we walked down to the end of this beach and,
um,
the wife and kids and me and my wife was the camera person.
And I found this,
I walked as far as I could,
uh,
until there was like this big black reef and all these rocks and everything.
And,
uh,
I'm like,
well this is as far as I can go.
And so you'd see the odd person walking down to the end then walking back.
But you couldn't be too close to the ocean because the waves are so loud.
And so we found this big rock that my wife kind of hide behind with a camcorder
cause the wind is,
uh,
it's,
it was windy.
And so the day,
two days before we left to go home,
uh,
I'm like,
I've got it.
Like I've got the masterpiece,
like all the best ideas.
And I was like,
every day I'd be like,
fine tuning things and trying them out.
And I'm like,
I'm ready to do it and I'm going to do it all in one shot.
Cause I want it to be the real deal.
Just like a Kettlebell class.
Right.
Because I think it's like 50,
58 minutes.
And I didn't even time that it was just luck because I've taught so many one
hour classes in my life,
but it was just like instinct.
And uh,
so yeah,
in all my favorite workouts are kind of on this first DVD.
At the time.
And so we went there,
filmed it,
um,
got back to the place I buried the Kettlebell on the beach cause I thought the
buried it on the beach.
Well,
cause I thought if I have any,
if there's any problems then I don't have to carry this thing cause I must have
walked like three miles or something with this thing on my back.
And it was like,
and I had to walk through this,
these different resorts all the way down the beach with my backpack.
And so you like x marks the spot if you have to come back.
He goes like,
go do it again.
Yeah.
I found the little,
made a little notch on the rock and buried this thing like pretty deep.
I mean,
I was paranoid.
I thought someone's going to steal my kettle bell,
but I don't think it would be stealing,
finding if that came to your house.
It'd be stealing.
You know,
you can't like leave your,
but on the beach.
He goes,
somebody stole it.
Oh,
fucking left it there,
dude.
They took it.
And,
uh,
actually when we were in Hawaii,
we,
uh,
I did bury my kettlebell on the beast because I'm too lazy to take it back up to
the room.
And there's these guys with the metal,
the metal detectors.
There's one guy,
he's like,
he always give me a wave.
He's like,
cause there were a couple times where he's digging this thing up and I'm like,
oh that's my kettle bell.
And he's like,
oh yeah.
Okay.
So you just leave it on the beach buried and then you come back and dig it up
the next day and work out with it.
Yeah.
You're lazy Bro.
Just carry that.
I know I got damn room.
It was wouldn't it be an extra workout?
Carry it up to your room.
The farmer's walk.
Yeah.
And exceptionalism.
Apparently the farmer's walk with one weight is far superior than doing it with
two weights.
Really?
Yeah.
Why is that?
Cause that co contraction on the opposite side.
That's what Stuart said.
So when you do the farmer's walk,
do you do x amount of paces with the right side and then switched to the left?
I think he was supposed to be that.
So That's interesting that it's superior if you're holding it on one side.
I would have thought just the opposite.
Really?
Yeah.
I would've thought it would be superior to have it equally balanced.
One weight on each side.
Well it's Kinda like when you go to the gym and you see guys working on their
obliques and they've got like the heavy dumbbells in each hand.
It's kind of like this one's pulling you this way and this one's plenty of that
way.
And I always say is that as good as just having one and doing it on one side and
then doing it on the other?
It's kind of like almost helps pull it over.
What's your take on two handed windmills?
Cause that's one of the exercises that I really love.
I love windmills with a Kettlebell and the chant.
And then when you drop the Kettlebell down you'd do a curl.
The kettlebell two hands anyhow,
is I what they call it?
Two hands.
Anyhow,
some men you remember that?
No,
but I like it.
I like that exercise.
It's a big one.
That's an excellent exercise.
Imagine the amount of force you're putting on the core compared to just one
kettlebell.
Well,
when I hurt my back,
uh,
from Jujitsu I really started concentrating more on back exercises and core
exercise and strengthening exercises because I recognize that there was this
injury that I was getting in Jujitsu was,
it was a weak link injury.
It's like there was a weak link in my chain and the weak link was the core.
My back,
I wasn't doing enough curls are not a curls,
Chin chin-ups rather rose.
I wasn't doing enough back exercises and I switched by workouts to almost
primarily that as opposed to a primarily pushing like benching and things along
those lines.
Yeah,
the um,
the two hands.
Anyhow,
that's a creative and you know,
that's just since we're on the subject of windmills,
that is one exercise that sometimes I see people going too deep with.
Like,
you should,
shouldn't,
you should.
There's that depth where it feels like your hamstrings are going to snap.
And I think that's where some people,
they'll take it just a little bit further so that they can touch the floor or
the ground or whatever.
If you can make sure that you're aware of where your body's ending up and keep
that core tight because there's that point where you get to the point where,
okay,
my hamstrings,
that's as far as they're going to go.
And then there's that little extra.
If you can stop short of that so that you maintain that nice super stiff core,
you probably already do that.
But some people that don't have as much flexibility and I watched myself on the
video the other day,
I was doing some homework and I'm going a little deeper than I should on some of
those windmills just cause I'm trying to look cool.
But uh,
for health wise and longevity wise,
if you can make sure that you maybe even check yourself in a mirror once in a
while,
make sure that your back doesn't move at all,
at the very bottom of that windmill farm.
Like sort of like how dips,
you're not supposed to go too low on dips.
If you go too low,
you put too much stress on the shoulders and too much stress on the tendon in
front of that shoulder capsule.
Hey,
you're just,
it's,
it's in a vulnerable position.
Hey,
so if you can go down to the point where you feel like if I go any further,
I'm just resting on my connective tissue.
If you can stop short of that,
you'll keep that tension on the muscles and it's,
but then there's an argument that your body should be able to do that.
Want to put your body into that stressful position,
make those connective tissue stronger.
So sort of like a low squat,
like dropping your body all the way down to here.
So I wouldn't say never do windmills nice and deep,
but if you're doing a lot of windmills,
be aware of,
uh,
how much of your back you're using at the very bottom portion.
But mind you,
that's a good thing.
With kettle bells,
you're usually,
most people aren't using so much weight that they have to worry about that.
Like even someone that's really advanced usually like they're not using much
more than 40 pounds or something like that for windmills.
Well,
I mean for part of the video,
like part of like the,
the extended work for your workouts.
Yeah.
Well when I do your workouts,
I do the windmill with,
I usually do 35 pounds or 45 pounds,
but when I do windmills just as a standalone,
I do seventies.
Yeah.
So it's just think it's,
it's a really great exercise for shoulder stability as well.
Yeah.
What about,
uh,
with getup?
Steagall pretty heavy on those two get ups upset.
17 you can't.
And it's such a neat exercise cause he can go super heavy and just,
uh,
yeah,
rarely give her on that.
Well,
it seems to me like a really good stability exercise.
Like as far as like your ability to maintain your stance,
maintain,
you're like pushing on things,
holding your ground.
I mean,
you're,
you're doing such a weird exercise,
just stand like that and it's so control based,
like dropping down,
laying flat,
holding the kettle bell up,
pressing it all over again.
Yeah.
That's a very good,
slow,
controlled exercise.
Keeps everything solid.
Yeah.
It's,
I love that one.
Um,
so anyway,
I looked at the video that we had taken that day and,
uh,
my wife is so honest.
I love it,
not about her.
And she looked at it and she's like,
you're doing it way too fast.
People aren't going to be able to keep up to this.
And,
uh,
I'm like,
oh,
and I did not want to do this again.
Right.
And of course I left it til the last day and I'm like,
Oh,
let me take a look at that.
And so I'm like,
Oh God,
that,
that is fast.
I'm just trying to get this over with Alex.
Terrible and fast.
Like too,
too fast.
Like an ineffective workout or too hard to do,
I think for a lot of people.
Maybe a little bit too little bit too little time between reputations.
Yeah.
A little bit too fast and uh,
but shouldn't this by aspire to be able to do it the way you're doing it?
Yeah.
Have you ever thought about doing like an advanced version for fucking people
like me?
[inaudible] well,
that's where the double Kettlebell,
when it's going to come up with,
you're going to love that.
Okay,
I'm not gonna eat my words.
Um,
and then I put it on the TV with the little cables and the wind noise was
insane.
It was like he couldn't hear a thing,
so he had to do it again.
Oh yeah.
I'm like,
Oh God,
we've got to go back there tomorrow.
I don't not only have to do one or two chapters over again,
I have to do the whole thing over again.
And I had like wicked a sand rash on my wrists,
like kettles hitting your rest,
you know,
my hands were pretty toughened up so they were okay.
But I'm just like,
Oh man,
this
is going to,
so that's why there's certain times during that video where I look like I'm
going to die.
I am like,
I'm,
I'm suffering.
So I hope that came out on the video because like I hope people watch this and
see like this is legit.
Like this guy's like suffering with me.
You know?
Definitely what you're working hard.
You're definitely,
well,
it's impossible to not be.
It's such a,
it's a brutal series of exercises.
It's awesome.
It do.
We're out of time man.
But your,
your videos are awesome.
I'm a huge fan.
I'm really happy that you came on here.
I hope more people buy them.
You can buy them at [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N.
I.
T we sell them there you have it on your website too.
What is your website?
People want to go to it.
A waiver,
physiotherapy.ca Weber,
physical physio,
physio,
physio for Canadian,
you know.
Oh,
that's why it's dot ca.
Yeah,
don't go to.com.
What happens if you go to Weber physio.com.
I don't know.
She try that two eight.
Someone's got it now.
Someone's got it and it's filled with decks.
It's all black decks guaranteed.
Thank you very much brother.
I really appreciate you so much.
Revelation gentlemen and Weber physio on Twitter.
You can um,
uh,
catch out or check out all of his videos again on,
on at.com and Weber,
physio.com.
Thank you very much brother.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much,
Keith Webb or ladies and gentlemen and thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Thanks to legal zoom.
Go to legal zoom.com and use the codeword Rogan at checkout to save yourself
some money.
Thanks also to stamps.com stamps.com enter in the code word j r e for your $110
bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
And thanks also to,
what's that?
Ting?
Yes.
Ting.
Yep.
Good.
Joe rogan.ting.com and save yourself
25 bucks off of any device today.
Was an audible to,
was it?
Nope.
No odd ball.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
audible.com forward slash Joe,
get a free,
you get a free book,
get a free audio book.
33 days of audible service.
All right,
that's it.
Anthony,
I coming up.
See you soon.
Big Kiss.
Hmm.
Hopefully for the people.